landry est mort mardi dernier à l'âge de
81 ans à la suite d'une longue maladie
pulmonaire et depuis vraiment de tous
les horizons politiques et de toutes les
générations
on a salué l'homme de conviction l'homme
de culture l'homme d'engagement pour le
service public
il parlait du québec de son québec comme
sa patrie il laisse un grand héritage
qui sera évoquée lors de la cérémonie
liturgique qui commencera dès 14 heures
cérémonie présidée par l'archevêque de
montréal monseigneur christian lépine et
il faut dont on connaît un peu les
détails de cette cérémonie
ce sera vraiment une cérémonie à son
image aussi fidèle à ses convictions
depuis l'enfance jusqu'à jusqu'à son
dernier souffle au fond et c'est vrai
pour le choix des textes les choix des
textes bibliques le choix des airs
sacrés de musique les choix de chansons
et de la chanson québécoise et d'ici là
nous irons voir sur ce parvis de la
basilique
les invités d'honneur qui commencent à
arriver qui vont lui rendre hommage à
l'entrée sur le plateau à mes côtés deux
anciennes ministres du parti québécois
deux anciennes collègues deux amis deux
femmes les femmes sur lequel il misait
beaucoup comme homme politique et homme
dans la vie aussi
on trouvait que cette cour de les réunir
avant qu'ils ne se rendent à la
cérémonie que c'est intéressant de vous
entendre madame britton interdit aux
marseillais bonjour je voudrais un bon
jour c'est vrai avoue unissant toutes
les deux sur ce plateau vous incarnez la
confiance qu'il avait envers les femmes
je vous reviens dans un instant juin
catherine gauthier sur le parvis
catherine alors y ajouter mari il ya
déjà des gens qui arrivent bien sûr oui
je vais vous montrer bien sûr autour de
moi parce que tout est très sécurisé
mais ça se fait dans le calme assurément
al marri la section ici c'est la section
des dignitaires des invités ya à peu
près un millier de personnes qui ont été
invitées et bien sûr de la famille
proche de monsieur landry mais aussi de
la grande famille politique
entre autres on a vu déjà arrivé
françois gendron alexandre cloutier
maka kotto également et de l'autre côté
donc derrière l'autre clôture c'est
l'entrée du public
il y as autotal 3000 places dans la
basilique notre dame anne marie et il y
a des gens du public qui veulent bien
sûr rendre hommage à monsieur l'entrée
on en a vu défiler hier dans cette
chapelle ardente est aujourd'hui c'est
la même chose alors il ya à peu près
2000 places pour le public donc on pense
que tous ceux qui veulent assister à
cette cérémonie vont pouvoir le faire
déjà on a commencé aussi à amener à leur
place les gens du public autour de 13h
30 tout le monde devrait être à
l'intérieur sauf monsieur legault qui va
arriver autour de 13h45 et la conjointe
de bernard landry chantal renaud ainsi
que les trois enfants de monsieur landry
vont arriver tout juste avant le début
de la cérémonie autour de 13h55 nous dit
on et par la suite bien ce sera la
cérémonie on me dit comme ce gendre ont
d'ailleurs
peut être entendu pour cent des moyens
je suis avec humanité il avec vision moi
je pourrais donner moult exemples parce
qu'on a siégé ensemble on peut noter des
priorités quand on était dans les cordes
cabinet de monsieur lévesque et une
vision de penser regardez le pacte
écologique à québec s'est lui même année
berne avait dit la ville de québec
pourra pas être toute sa vie une ville
de fonctionnaires et c'est pas péjoratif
pendant toute là pour penser que je
porte des joueurs des gars de siffler
mais c'est partout de l'accomplissement
la cité du multimédia un programme où ça
vous dit pour la marque qui opinent du
bonnet c'était de l'audace c'était de la
vision de la détermination c'est cette
capacité de voir grand lorsqu'on
social-démocrate pourvu que le panier de
services soit bien nourrie il faut
générer plus de richesses c'est une
règle fondamentale et spawn question des
tours omnibulé par l'économie mais quand
on veut mieux répartir faut savoir que
l'attaqué la richesse une forme de
richesse par les opérations l'économie
sociale cds galvin de la richesse non
bernard manger est plein de bons
souvenirs restent un fier représentant
des régions du québec et en particulier
de la mienne mais combien de fois ils
m'ont rendu service du moment dit mince
immensément service en abitibi jouer
dans ma tête le métal marquis quand il a
créé sa part le programme en osier tkp
aujourd'hui 180 puis il serait si le
directeur général de métal mcgeady
windows et le programme aux kids est
lancé et je suis sûr que cette suite
mais gardent aujourd'hui le faux faux
faux salué ce grain comme cet homme
extraordinaire cultivé comme c'est pas
passé barre à terre généreuse joker
toujours présent un militant un patriote
alors monsieur gendron qui vient de
quitter la vie politique le doyen la
méthode vous incarnez à la fois comme
femme première délégué général du québec
à new york
nommé par lui
l'importance des femmes qui doit jouer
des rôles en économie mais dayraut
important et vous lui rendez j'imagine
hommage pour soi aussi
obi absolument et je pense que c'est
plus le fait des femmes c'était la
compétence qu'il recherchait dans tout
ce qui ce qui l'entourait chercher le
meilleur des gens et dans le cas de la
cantine approché pour la délégation
il m'avait dit elle avait donné un gros
rapport à la fin des discussions avaient
dû voici ce qu'on perçoit du québec
vous allez mettre le québec sur la carte
annie a tellement mal moi rien n'a
beaucoup d'ambition pour le québec à
l'international et vous louise comme
faim de culture mais de la culture
également l'économie ça se conjugue
toujours la culture ou six fois une
économie forte pour que la culture soit
oui soit faufilé hier la culture ou si
ça signifie des dix ans après une vie
des entreprises et puis bon tous les
toutes les industries culturelles sauf
que bernard avait compris même dans le
cadre des accords de libre-échange vicky
tard il aurait changé c'est un bon un
chantre du libre-échange qu'il fallait
une exception culturelle
parce que la culture ce n'est pas
seulement de l'économie c'est aussi ça
une double nature et chats bernard
landry c'est formidable parce que il a
été avec donc le gouvernement 98,1
dépend du gouvernement au monde à
prendre parti cette question là oui aux
accords de libre échange
mais oui à l'exception culturelle pour
les sorties des accords de libre-échange
mme amara était un complice
extraordinaire bas dans tout ce
cheminement l'avers l'exception
culturelle
je retourne sur le parvis au madame de
lille michel va dire un mot pour cela
quand il tente
nous parlait c'était du bonheur oui les
lits vont se souvenir c'est un gars
grand patriote
ouais c'est parce que c'est sûr va
dépendre large
jack est important merci de me michel
grands artistes oui donc louise beaudoin
est ce qu'on peut dire que monsieur
landry parce qu'on va parler de la
cérémonie est à l'image de ce qu'il a
été à travers les témoignages une
dizaine de témoignages vont être
entendus mais dans les choix musicaux ça
commence sur gens de mon pays
il se termine par par là que la fontaine
on va écouter monsieur marché j'avais à
ses tresses comme au développement
économique et aux finances comme lui et
ses stratégies étaient toujours là c'est
un passionné du développement du québec
qui passait pas c'est que l'économie
était fondamental je partageais ses
convictions dans les grands centres que
dans les régions mal québec c'est un
tout c'est une famille il faut s'occuper
de tout neuf mais c'était sa passion
alors monsieur bachand qui était de la
famille péquiste un certain moment qui a
changé les gens ils ne nourrissait pas
d'inimitié nécessairement avec les
adversaires parce qu'elle est une
réalité monsieur non monsieur landry
certains le craignaient certains les
mains mais tout le monde le respecte
pour ce qu'il est et pour ce qu'il
diffusait aussi cette fierté d'être un
du pays du québec c'était sa marque de
commerce et voulait que ce pays à se
développe se développe sur le plan
économique sur le plan culturel sur tous
les plans nous à travers c'est au micro
non c'est maintenant monsieur duceppe
loser après lorsque mes amis de la
famille une amie de
de chantal renaud une amie de monsieur
l'envi doucet ses enfants
e
non seulement pour la perte de berlin
mais c'est l'immense sam d'amour
qu'elles ont reçues depuis quelques
jours en même temps extrêmement fatigué
c'est il faut il faut prendre soin d'eux
mais jean l'on perd un grand homme et je
t'ai heureux que il est tant de gens
qu'ils lui rendent hommage aujourd'hui
on perd un grand homme politique mais un
ami et puis ben évidemment bernard pour
nous c'était sa voix qui va nous manquer
ces propos au jour j sur les changes
qu'on avait avec lui
alors tout ce qu'il a fait pour le
québec
c'était un grand homme plus grand que
nature
with good way dans raison c'est que
bernard a été je donne un décor
politique si longtemps et il a réussi en
effet est-ce que je devrais sa sortie on
voit aujourd'hui jusqu'à quel point
cette dans la durée oui bernard a fait
beaucoup de choses là semblent voilà
dans la durée et c'est vrai que tous
ceux qui vont prendre la parole vont le
prouver d'ailleurs tout à l'heure que
cette jury a donné des résultats
extraordinaires puis c'est vrai que
bernard représente quelque chose de très
très près sculier pour la grée les
pirates est un excellent exemple de
collaboration avec les négligents deux
des autres parties paiera quand le chef
intérimaire facile mais pas le plus
méchant premier ministre avec évidemment
beaucoup de grâce et or on est tous
ensemble tous les partis politiques
aujourd'hui pour lui rendre cet hommage
qu'il m'est bien s'apprécier de tout le
monde
les rôles au sens large mais c'est sûr
mais même à l'international
si l'on part une lettre de monsieur
juppé qui va être lu tout à l'heure et
je revenais à ses choix musicaux
oui mais très important qu alain juppé
justement soit présent par la parole
sera pas présent physiquement mais cette
relâche avec l'ail et le président
d'ubisoft traduit exactement ça cette
double ils étaient de vrais nord
américain comme toujours mais ça
charles agents avec la france elle était
très étroite très influent l'américain
cause du libre échange absolu alisation
il n'y avait jamais oublié d'où il
venait
et je reviens parce qu avant de vous
laisser partir cette cérémonie qui va
témoigner de son grand parcours de saint
jacques de montcalm
alors qu'il tenait un discours et
chanter les belles chansons de la vega
de bois en passant par gervinho et
d'autres chants sacrés louise il la
cérémonie qui va durer quand même un
beau temps va se terminer sur la latte
l'air fontaine et c'était l'hymne
nationale des patriotes dans les
chansons de la brigade bois vous avez
des souvenirs mais certainement pas un
hasard oui je le souvenir très
particulier acquis bête non les années
90 chez nos amis jacques et francine
djelic la france elle joue du piano bon
et michel rocard et là il vient d'être
démis de ses fonctions par françois
mitterrand il était premier ministre de
france depuis trois ans pour laver
hésité à venir à québec bernard et moi
justement disant bon bah vous s'occuper
de ses amis et avec bernard landry ils
ont chanté et c'est là qu'on voit qu'il
ya quand même une une relation très
intenses entre la france et qui remonte
justement à ces temps là et on a chanté
tous ensemble c'est si la chanson de la
vega de bois illégal escota aussi muller
de juillet michel record a été longtemps
une protestants mais ce coup ci après
sont alors c'était des soirées mais
celle-là a été dans mon dans mon
imaginaire elle est restée une trace
lorsque c'est l'importance de l'histoire
commencé avec gilles vigneault gens de
mon pays finir avec avec la fontaine un
champ du 15e siècle et aussi on va
entendre une chanson de stéphane venne
est un praticien pendant vidéo trouvera
la paix qui a été interprété aux
funérailles de leur aide la porte vers
épouse décédée en 99
donc c'est un homme de continuité de
fidélité à totalement totalement il
avait il avait
des principes de support moi je ne
connaissais pas d'ennemis mais même en
face le comme on dit il
il était apprécié de tout le monde et
s'occupait de tout le monde je ne lis je
ne me souviens pas avoir entendu
quelqu'un dire monsieur landry de
promouvoir et monsieur landry que l'on
dit il le fait de la politique pour les
bonnes raisons
oui oui c'est pas le plus grand
compliment qu'on puisse faire avoue
unitaire de cynisme et de désamour à
londres la bonne raison qu'il n'a jamais
varié je n'ai jamais vraiment bon voila
il
il a été du début à la fin bon certains
indépendantistes bernard bon qui a cru
jusqu'à la fin il est mort 100 pays il
titre est de voir mes mais quand même
bon et je trouve que c'est vraiment un
très bel hommage le convent durant bien
mérité comment faire comment vous allez
vivre cette cérémonie je vais vous
laisser partir dans un instant comment
vous allez la vie cette cérémonie avait
beaucoup d'émotion je pense parce que en
tout cas pour moi ça a été une personne
ressource
il ya un appui continu et un au late
un état de fait pour vous mais moi ça a
été un complice ont amené tellement de
batailles ensemble et je pense alors
elle en était le maire
réponse est je pense à chantal et qui a
été pour lui les dernières années on
étale en offrant son talent est lyon
ensemble il ya exactement deux ans on
est à lyon ensemble à l'université lyon
iii et chantal a été vraiment à est
fatigué
à ses côtés je lâche à lui très
franchement alors c'est la mère de
famille aussi qu'on va célébrer ce soir
oui et sa famille c'était le québec sa
famille village
mais tous les autres parce qu'on va on
voit justement la chapelle qui commence
à se remplir on va vous laisser filer
louise beaudoin josiane marcelet irait
de condoléances oui on va écouter mario
beaulieu et de tous les autres impôts
des nations 6
merci
alors voilà les gens continuent de fuir
vers la basilique notre dame à montréal
la cérémonie présidée par monseigneur
christian lépine va commencer vers à 14h
c'est ce qui est prévu et on voit les
parlementaires vont madame diane lemieux
qui arrive et on va on va entendre
maintenant l'ancien maire de montréal
monsieur pierre bouquet jeunesse
richelieu lui tu vois c'est marrant
c'est très beau très tragique
le meunier partie moi quand manger
beaucoup connu parce qu'on a fait le
site et du multimédia cesser son oeuvre
lui moi je les ai aidés parce que
c'était à moriat la cité aussi commerce
électronique et tout ça m'a beaucoup
touché
ça m'a dit 'maintenant ça a touché tous
les québécois mais ce thème était très
fort très vivant il marchait vers ça
tous les jours
on le voit quand j'ai vu cet été c'était
chaud il a beaucoup d'émules québec
alain fages faut que va continuer ou si
nous appris comment aimer notre pays où
vous voilà il voulait que les québécois
eux aussi croire ne même croire leur
plein potentiel d'aller au bout d'eux
mêmes et c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a
fait preuve d'une d'une consistance
d'une persistance d'une complète dans
toute sa vie pour se battre pour ses
idées et ses idéaux et je pense que ça
sert or est ce ça doit être souligné je
pense que de voir autant de québécois
ici aujourd'hui
ça montre à quel point les québécois ça
centre à dora rossi semble qui leur
donnait beaucoup puis veulent témoigner
à leur tour aujourd'hui
mais mon état d'esprit cessé de dire
merci monsieur landré c'est de dire
merci d'avoir consacré autant d'énergie
au québec d'avoir permis au temps de
bâtir le québec
économiquement culturellement c'est un
amoureux de la culture
moi je suis députée de joliette il vient
de saint jacques de montcalm il s'est
présenté deux fois dans joliette et
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
il prenait des présidence d'honneur à
joliette à saint jacques
il est elle toujours toujours pour des
levées de fonds il a vraiment donné sa
vie au service public alors moi je me
souviens lui comme d'un être vraiment
hors norme hors du commun qui représente
le service public et la quête de son
idéal que jamais lâché que jamais
abdiqué je pense que c'est un
extraordinaire exemple pour nous tous
monsieur landry la région de joliette et
qui rend hommage
véronique hivon qui va poursuivre sa
politique avec une page de monsieur
landry on voit les grandes orgues
il y aura au cours de cette cérémonie
plusieurs chants religieux marie nicole
lemieux
la contralto et la grande la grande
solistes invités on écoute la
ministation des amis madame les cadences
ans québec monsieur landry offert une
contribution importante pour les
québécois et nous recueillir là
aujourd'hui
c'est très très important du souvenir
vraiment de tout ce qu'il a fait pour le
québec alors vraiment c'est un moment
important et
en fait tout le monde tout le québec
importe
je suis cette cérémonie avec beaucoup
beaucoup de recueillement versant des
partis politiques au siv ensemble des
partis politiques absolument pas ce que
écouter tous les partis politiques ont
des grands hommes
monsieur landry des grandes femmes et
monsieur landry était un grand homme et
voyez à l'intérêt de tous les québécois
alors ça transcende les partis
politiques
la venue de la santé madame danielle
mécanique on a vu au bas de l'écran
l'arrivée du maire de québec monsieur
régis labeaume on disait tout à l'heure
il y aura mille invités parmi lesquels
les parlementaires les dignitaires les
représentants des grandes institutions
québécoises sa compagnie au cours des
prochaines heures par notre chef du
bureau à québec si bastien bravais
bonjour ses personnages et michel david
krüger politique aux devoirs qui était
déjà à québec dans les premières années
où monsieur landry était déjà mené ce
gouvernement vous avez commencé votre
retour dans les années 80 avec te manger
dormir son mandat était encore ministre
d'état au développement économique
précédentes où le deuxième mandat de
monsieur lévesque
alors on a mais cela vaut au micro le
puits créatif qui a osé le plus dans les
dernières décennies il le fait parce
qu'il avait tellement confiance en son
pays le québec
moi j'ai eu à faire etc lui jamais il ne
peut ainsi que unis n'étaient pas
exécutées avait été pour transformer en
un projet concret et c'est rare en
politique parce que les policiers sont
généralement un peu craintif pour ne pas
dire plus heureux lui cet imposant comme
c'est un gars formidable toujours
confiant toujours malgré l'épisode cet
aspect il il recevait les idées il
n'avait jamais dit fou il n'y avait pas
que des folles c'était toujours passé
même si tu es à la limite il voulait
savoir s'il y avait une possibilité
d'exécuter les idées c'est rare c'est
très rare et moi je vais à faire avec et
à 3 pour que je peux vous dire qu'à pour
qui est extraordinaire parce que québec
sous son règne comme ministre des
finances n'est visible beaucoup à r&d et
à l'innovation technologique il était
toujours là et à part ça il adorait
québec michel il aimait québec
il aimait québec beaucoup à ce que la
capitale nationale cet aspect là je
pense que outre les chambres avec bien
sûr mais pour monsieur monsieur landry
c'était vraiment le berceau de la nation
québécoise et il pestait on a beaucoup
parlé d'une chiffon rouge mais il
trouvait que façon générale il y avait
beaucoup de drapeaux canadiens
beaucoup de ces effectivement il prenait
une marche tous les matins sur les
plaines d'abraham en équilibre et un
symbole ils piétinaient la victoire
britannique sont les peintres et jacques
de montcalm
il avait fortement calme en lui sur son
cas alors je crois un an et demi on a
parlé en long et en large ce qu'on
devrait faire en termes de développement
économique au québec donc c'était c'est
juste pour moi c'est sa marque de
commerce
définitivement moi j'ai eu l'occasion de
croiser souvent souvent comme une
immigration se retrouver souvent au même
événement était toujours tellement
gentil tellement charmant tellement
intelligent si discours allumé alors
c'est un titre très personnel aussi qu'
il va me manquer mais aussi on voit la
passion de l'homme l'intelligence de
l'homme la brillance de l'homme tous ces
reportages sur lui celui-ci aussi pour
reconnaître que cet homme exerce ce
leader extraordinaire
monsieur landry qui a été ministre de
l'immigration puis quand on regarde le
déroulement de cette cérémonie
aujourd'hui il a voulu laisser une
grande place à la diversité culturelle
du québec ce qui n'était pas du tout
contradictoire avec son patriotisme et
la défense québec québec nations
sébastien à l'achat pélardon de monsieur
landry aussi toutes sortes de corps
consulaire de diplomates de différents
pays et de tous les horizons vraiment
qu'ils sont venus lui rendre hommage
donc il avait tissé des liens à
l'étranger et il était très proche des
communautés culturelles aussi sauf
erreur il avait été très choqué par la
déclaration de monsieur parizeau le soir
du référendum il avait ici de retisser
des liens avec les communautés
culturelles par la suite en effet ils
pensaient que souvent dépassé par
l'adhésion des communautés culturelles
au projet du parti québécois natale mais
s'ils avaient déstabilisé au fameux
débat parce que monsieur charest avait
sorti fédérer eu je dis au conditionnel
qui aurait eu
nouvelle fois par la voix de son pari
zone déclarations dans le même sens le
jour même du débat s'est en grande
partie est embêtant pour monsieur landry
parce qu'il savait parce que monsieur
manon parisot avait dit et je pense pas
certain que monsieur charest le savez
exactement lui non plus parce que c'est
là que c'est le fameux audi alteram
partem faut écouter donner la parole aux
autres avant de juger avant de conclure
qui a été très présent dans ce
documentaire le suivi jusqu'à la fin de
la campagne puisse donner l'impression
aux gens que monsieur landry elle ne
voulait pas condamner et on lui on lui a
prêté des pensées qu'il n'avait
certainement pas ce sens va coûter pas
de redressement et ce canadien du
patrimoine et qui est lui a souri
puisque je cale effet la connaît mais il
leur est vécue dans quelques mots c'est
illustre ce qui était bernard landry un
homme de conviction et si la raison pour
laquelle peut-être qu'on est un peu
surpris de du concert d'éloges mais
c'est un homme de conviction c'est ce
qui plaît aux rouges
mario dumont et au micro mais toutes les
étapes quelqu'un de et que de profonds
et de profondément documenté à dire que
pour moi des batailles comme le libre
échange que cette auto plaçants 88 10
pour faire sa part pour tunis ne pouvait
pas voir c'est aujourd'hui salaires
évident et c'est à ce moment-là il
prenait restée alliés syndicaux était
pote son bord au premier moment donc six
ans lui vaut plusieurs coups d'avancé où
le québec doit aller puis lui s'envole
au pif ans je pense c'est ça qu'on
retient aujourd'hui
maintenant pour moi l'autre volet d'un à
landry cette semaine on a vu ça on
connaissait peu sa famille se nomme bien
été assez discret trop de source et sur
ses enfants
mais on eu comment ils sont comment ils
ont accueilli le public put up et on
comprend mieux de l'amour qui avait dans
cette maison là de du bord de l'eau à
verchères la famille de son sens de la
famille la façon dont ils ont
véhicules day trading match hier je suis
je pas sa chapelle ardente donc 500 voix
on découvre à son décès un autre côté
personnel de bernard landry l'homme de
famille le père sûrement aimant si on
devine tout ce qui s'est passé dans la
maison avant pour que ces enfants
aujourd'hui se comporte de cette façon
là c'est aussi très beau alors mario
dumont avec qui il a vécu monsieur en
ville le référendum de 1995 de plus près
étant donné que monsieur dumont était
dans ce triangle vous y voient une
faveur faite des parties du triumvirat
mais vous disais tantôt même les
adversaires puis les gens sont souvent
surprise du doigt l'hypocrisie mais il
faut voir que il ya deux faces en deux
deux personnages c'est un peu docteur
jekyll et mr hyde c'est sûr que monsieur
landry en chambre ou quand il était dans
le débat public qui pouvait être féroce
mais autant il pouvait être féroce au
temps il pouvait être très agréable et
tous ces gens me font un peu partie du
même club le quinqua elle ajouté est
terminée ils sont parfaitement capables
de faire peser et de lier des maîtres
des amitiés ou si c'est pas c'est pas
hypocrite et d amitié basée sur le
respect ils sont 125 au québec avoir la
même fonction donc un club relativement
select ils vivent les mêmes choses et
même s'ils n'ont pas les mêmes
convictions les mêmes la même idéologie
politique sont capables de respecter
l'idéologie et les convictions de
l'autre et bernard landry était si
convaincu de son idéologie ou de 2 du
projet qu'il voulait réaliser que ça
entraînait le respect de ses adversaires
politiques qui voyait en lui comme les
québécois voir voyant bernard landry un
homme convaincu tia koné vient d'émettre
un commentaire
monsieur landry parce qu'il était à
l'université de montréal ensemble on
peut écouter
d'accord
annoncé ces bons ballons devant
mais cela en dos c'est important pour
vous d'être ici aujourd'hui très
important à deux titres
parce que bernard landry a été un
compagnon d'université
des facultés de droit et que j'admirais
beaucoup de joie y avait du leadership
de l'éloquence et ils prenaient toutes
sortes d'initiatives pour que notre
association d'étudiants de l'université
de montréal l époque ne soit pas
strictement une organisation qui fait
des danses et des activités sociales on
revendiquait on voulait obtenir un
recteur laïque
à l'époque il était religieux et on veut
obtenir aussi comme les êtres humains de
laser son époque c'est vers enterrer
quelqu'un qui travaille très fort pour
le québec la sûreté du québec
la fin d'une époque oui mais c'est
j'espère que ça va être un sursaut dans
une bon sens pour la souveraineté du
québec aussi mais les tout débuts quand
on était jeune quand j'étais jeune
attaché de presse
les têtes jeune ministre d'état au
développement économique
alors des beaux projets à cette époque
là oui la venue de bordeaux super
évidemment monsieur lévesque au parti
québécois de la crédibilité à ce
discours là et donc il y avait une
conscience des étapes à suivre sur le
plan économique parce que là la peur à
l'époque des souvent évoqué comme étant
un obstacle majeur à son rêve
oui parce que monsieur d'abord monsieur
parizeau mais ensuite monsieur landry
c'était à peu près les deux seuls
il en porte parole économique le crédit
bleus au sein du parti ou connu enfin au
sein du pq et s'est développée par la
suite longtemps mais super iso avait été
l'adjoint économique de monsieur
lévesque
monsieur landry devenu à jouer le même
rôle auprès du sien j'essaie de craintes
au micro pour appliquer monsieur landry
était l'instigateur la paix des braves
en écoute à la mise en place d'une telle
de tels espaces et c'est le fait que le
parti québécois sans doute beaucoup plus
que n'importe quelle autre partie
comprend mieux les aspirations des
premiers peuples au niveau de la
propreté d'amis donc je crois que la
paix des braves
est-ce qu'il va y en avoir d'autres
c'est une question je pense que tout le
certainement de gouvernement présents à
se poser d'ailleurs ça a été avancée il
faudra maintenant trouver un espace
adéquat pour en parler nous écouter
pour au risque de me répéter la paix des
braves parce que c'était un engagement
quand même il a été premier ministre
quand même dans un temps qui est
relativement court donc ça lui a permis
d'engager
la nation crie en particulier vers la
conclusion de cet important importante
entente ce qu'il faut sans doute
signaler ici c'est que la paix des
braves est issu d'une démarche politique
et qui est malheureusement pas assez
souvent au rendez vous ce qui fait
quelqu'un qui nous quitte
à l'arrivée ça qui les entendra va
repartir on se débrouille j'espère qu'il
les entend pas ce que bernard landry
était quelqu'un qui était extrêmement
soucieux de de la trace qu'il laisse est
pour le québec il était amoureux du
québec
il travaillait comme un fou il y avait
une énergie débordante et l'ours qui a
pris personnellement à la cause de de
l'emploi et la modernisation du québec
il était sur toutes les tribunes ils
étaient dans tous les dossiers il
voulait sauver tous les emplois ils
voulaient attirer tout dit avec tous les
investisseurs mais aussi voulait que ça
se sache nous l'ex h et ces derniers
jours en voyant l'ensemble des hommages
qui lui sont faits dia bernard ça c'est
le sas et là on se rend compte que
l'économie du québec aujourd'hui icône
étant désinhibé audacieuses ambitieuses
et s'était pas donné d'avancé bernard
landry qui a fait ça il y avait une
ambition il y avait une audace il n'y
avait aucune inhibition surtout ce que
le québec pouvait réaliser puis
aujourd'hui le montréal puis québec
d'aujourd'hui où on invente
l'intelligence artificielle les jeux
vidéo l'hérault nautique de demain c'est
un petit peu l'héritage de bernardi même
ce qu'ils savent pas même ceux qui n'ont
jamais entendu parler en fait leur
audace vient il ya une dose de bernard
landry dans l'audace de l'économie
québécoise au jour et je pense qu'il
serait très fière de l'entendre dire pi2
de voir que c'est enfin reconnue pour
moi qui est membre du parti québécois
depuis 1987
monsieur landry a été un modèle de
militantisme modèle d' de conviction
pour l'indépendance du québec
je les ai vu la dernière fois au mois de
mai ou gala des patriotes
on a vu un bel échange al assad mort
quelqu'un s'allumant extraordinaire et
je joue toujours
il faut jamais oublier sa contribution
dans le développement des régions les
régions du québec
aujourd'hui mais cinq autres on s'est
surtout la mémoire le souvenir de envers
monsieur landry aussi toujours un
soutien envers la famille dans ces
moments là on est toujours à penser aux
contributions pour l'état mais pour son
épouse c'est un mari qui est qui marque
c'est en face un père pour les
petits-enfants son grand père alors ça
ça nous ramène au concorso savoie
cérémonie de souvenir parce que les
envols veulent garder landry à l'esprit
puis vivant parce que les gens ont
besoin que les grands personnages ne
disparaît sport comme ça rapidement
je pense que cette cérémonie hausse et
c'est pour lui rendre hommage mais c'est
aussi pour faire en sorte que les gens
se souviennent
ce sera fait à propos et éventuellement
de songer à ce que son nom reste de
façon matérielle mais j'ai l'impression
que j'ai l'impression que maintenant qui
est partie la coutume c'est que les
grands personnages finissent par avoir
quelque chose qui fait que max a peut
être un pont en barrage peu importe
peut-être que
la paix des braves est ce que ça a
permis peut-être qu'on sait jamais je
disais qu'il y avait je pense que
moubarak avait fait appel après 10
braves qui portait le nom de je sais pas
trop quoi du père peut-être que ça
pourrait être le barrage à bernard
landry me trudel ya qui parlait
peut-être de changer de nom à metz on
doit changer non éventuellement où vous
êtes pour la rue de la paix des braves
oui ce serait une chose mais ce serait
bon à l'ona de landry mais ça va être la
paix des braves
l'espèce de comment je peux dire de de
réconciliation entre les québécois et
puis les peuples autochtones mais c'est
un hommage indirect mais si on veut
donner si on veut se souvenir avec un
nom donc le nom de landry lui même bien
que j'ai l'impression que le temps de
repos des siècles avant que sa quantité
de réalisations qu'il a son crédit on a
l'embarras du choix
c'est ça je peux pas j'ai pas à moi de
déterminer ce que savard est alors
jean-pierre charbonneau qui a été
président l'assemblée nationale mais à
la fin souvent dans l'ombre et qui a été
ministre des institutions démocratiques
en vue d'une réforme il évoquait la paix
des braves et là je fais le lien avec
ghislain picard qui a parlé juste avant
que ça c'est pas rien monsieur picard de
dire je crois que le parti québécois
comprend mieux les besoins la réalité
des autochtones des premières nations
je pense que oui
la paix des braves mais souvenez-vous
c'est leur nom de monsieur lévesque qui
le premier avait reconnu les les nations
autochtones et il a nécessité de parler
d'égal à égal y avait un pas qui avait
été fait dans ce sens là mais y est
certain que il y avait eu la bdg la
convention de la baie james qui était
aussi un bel exemple de collaboration
mais la paix des braves je pense que
dans dans l'esprit d'un peu tout le
monde est de toute évidence c'est aussi
ce que pense monsieur monsieur picard
c'est le modèle à partir duquel
maintenant on va essayer de négocier des
ententes et si sébastien quand on entend
dire une bonne dose de l'audace de dans
l'économie québécoise de la part de
monsieur de monsieur landry puis
monsieur la bombe tantôt qui disait le
maire de québec avec des bonnes ce dj
mais non voyons monsieur landry un
politicien comme il devrait tout cela
est oui quelqu'un qui est prêt prêt à
prendre des risques quand on parle de
visionnaire c'est peut-être ça aussi qui
nous raccroche à bernard landry canton
de plus avancé
la vision qu'il avait le libre échange à
88 les
les jeux vidéo le multimédia à la fin
des années 90 avait des gens qui disent
ça n'a pas de bon sens qui intervient
dans ce domaine là et ça revêtent
revitaliser c'est ce que hubert bolduc
d'isis à revitaliser tout un quartier du
vieux montréal qui était lui y dit on va
en est d'aider des raquettes puis des
casquettes des expos dans ce cas c'est
là il y avait des boutiques comme ça
dorénavant c'est des bouts de cdd des
bureaux de multimédia de création de
jeux vidéo donc il avait une vision puis
il était capable de prendre des risques
aussi et c'est ce que bien des gens sont
venus aujourd'hui tu renvoies monsieur
mulcair monsieur mulcair qui a été un
collègue en fait à l'assemblée nationale
des échanges je pouvais morts et 2 en
effet et on a vu arriver des autres dit
dans le vus avait monsieur bouchard
monsieur charest ils vont prendre la
parole pendant la cérémonie ne se sont
pas arrêtés au micro pour le moment je
pense qu'il a su recueillir parce que
prendre la parole dans un événement
aussi solennel je peux à peine imaginer
la dose de stress que ça représente pour
choisir les bons mots quand on veut
rendre hommage à un homme que l'on
reconnaît comme un grand orateur
lui-même exactement ce sommet de la
pression mais en même temps on m'a dit
que c'est bernard landry lui même s'ils
avaient choisi les orateurs aujourd'hui
donc si jean charest y est si lucien
bouchard y est et tous les autres que
vous aurez aujourd'hui c'est parce que
monsieur landry voulait qu'il y soit et
moi on me dit que jean charest pour un a
été extrêmement touché lorsqu'il a reçu
l'appel et qu'on lui a demandé de 2,2 de
prononcer quelques mots à aux
funérailles d'état de monsieur oui je
sais un petit mot monsieur sauf erreur
c'est bastien qui arrivera mais c'est
que c'est jean charest qui avait décidé
je sais pas c'est pas le soit aussi ces
photos là qui à partir de voiles à
carter ii
de santé tout le monde les anciens
premiers ministres conserveraient leur
site et je pense que ça avait beaucoup
faire plaisir à monsieur landry et c'est
pour ça qu'on parle des funérailles du
premier ministre baird alors ici parce
qu'on parle du premier ministre bouchard
du premier ministre charest qui vont
venir prononcer quelques bons ils
gardent leurs titres comme les
présidents des états unis comme un 18
ans français de l'impression française
envoie le premier ministre belge thomas
qui arrive alors ne nous écrivait pas
mesdames messieurs ce n'est pas une
erreur quand on parle de monsieur
charest comme le premier ministre ou de
monsieur bouchard comme le pôle unis
c'est une question reconnu par le grand
l'ordre national du québec qui parle le
premier sur charest alors le premier
ministre du québec accompagné de sa
femme madame isabelle bray on va
l'écouter
monsieur landry c'est un homme d'état
exceptionnel c'est on l'a souvent dit un
homme de devoir
il le disait pour lui c'était la patrie
avant de participer
je pense qu'on doit prendre exemple sur
lui a toujours fait passer le bien de
l'ensemble des québécois avant le bien
du parti québécois et c'est un homme
aussi évidemment qu'ils étaient amoureux
du québec qui aimait le québec puisque
réussi à communiquer cet amour je pense
que je pense que grâce à bernard landry
les québécois sont encore plus fier des
québécois donc comme premier ministre du
québec
moi je veux de la part de tous les
québécois d merci monsieur landry un
break quelques commandes d'à côté c'est
un homme tout à fait sympathique et très
intéressant à écouter aussi parce que
moi je me souviens d'avoir vu des
discours fait sans papiers ça m'a
toujours impressionné vraiment vraiment
j'applique justement que quand on a une
responsabilité politique
avant nous intérêts personnels avant les
intérêts de notre pas si on doit passer
l'intérêt supérieur
bon évidemment moi qui est un passionné
d'économie j'ai beaucoup appris avec lui
aussi sur l'économique
c'est l'économie du québec parker la
région par région industrie par
industrie donc c'était vraiment
professeur extraordinaire pour apprendre
comme il faut l'économie du québec
merci tout le monde le sait pas ce qu on
dit que les conseils des ministres
présidé par de landry avait une allure
tout à fait particulière monsieur
legault au japan beaucoup de sons oui
monsieur le voit après tout ce genre de
choses monsieur landry y compris qu'en
politique il ya des coups qui viennent
qui voit pas venir
souvenez-vous que monsieur legault avait
des velléités de succéder à jean charest
qui raconte une espèce d'alliance avec
pauline marois est très habilement il a
complètement aussi de monsieur le gouda
la famille dans la fête dans la farine
et monsieur legault mais je le serai
peut-être les critiques pas dans ses
mémoires me raconter une fois comment ça
s'était passé est vraiment il était
resté un peu baba la face à la façon
dont il s'y était pris oui j'ai beaucoup
appris de mes rencontres mais moi ce
qu'on me dit c'est que souffert un
michel vastel dans un livre que appeler
ça la guerre de six jours parce que ça a
duré six jours où les gilles baril
semble-t-il qui était le proche de
monsieur landry récupérer des députés
pour appuyer bernard landry pour mettre
fin cette course là où c'est emmanuel
constans et aux velléités de monsieur et
de madame marois mais bien pourquoi
parce qu'ils avaient un sondage léger
messieurs landry avait préparé son
affaire il y avait un sondage léger
jamais caché qu'ils mettaient monsieur
landry très en avance sur tous les
autres
alors monsieur landry peu de téléphone
et appeler par exemple ou de baudouin
demandait ce que tu m'as puis oui je
tape hui quand même avoir réalisé que
madame madame beaudoin pierre landry
c'était cuit l'amour c'était il ya
quelques jours
ah ouais mais ça a été très vite fait
pour solliciter ses appuis là monsieur
landry avait fait miroiter des choses
qui ne sont pas nécessairement été qui
sont pas décemment réalisé par la suite
mais ça m'était très habile c'est la
règle du jeu mais par la suite ça a été
moins drôle parce que monsieur legault a
continué à entretenir des ambitions et
pendant toute l'année qui a précédé le
congrès de 2005 lorsqu'elle monsieur
landry a démissionné il y avait
l'impression que monsieur legault lui
souffler dans le cou
passablement est donc la dernière année
a été il ya eu de la tension entre les
deux hommes il s'appelle je sais pas si
vous aussi vous qu'il écrivait ce matin
mais que même si monsieur landry était
resté après le vote de 76%
il y aurait eu du grenouillage derrière
lui notamment de françois legault et
peut-être d'autres personnes et
peut-être de personnes en effet dans
l'esprit monsieur l'avez peut-être les
gens qui l'avaient poussé vers la sortie
convaincu d'accepter ce verdict de 76
pourtant pour ça comme un désaveu au
fond il voulait faire plus que lucien
bouchard ce que je pense quelques de ce
mal de plus mais honnêtement je pense
qu'ils auraient survécu
souvenons nous qu'en même que le pq
était comme 15 points en avance d'un
stage à ce moment qu'ils ont pris et
chroniquement dire que 76% au pq c'est
comme 92% tellement peur que le chef par
et puis on va poursuivre cette émission
spéciale en hommage
au premier ministre bernard landry c'est
finir avec des tags qui devrait
commencer à 14 heures cérémonie présidée
par l'archevêque de montréal monseigneur
christian lépine ont fait une brève
pause bona messieurs et ont peu dessus
cette émission
la poursuite de la dignité et de
l'indépendance nationale ne tient à
aucun sentiment agressif roi aucun
ressentiment
la poursuite de l'idéal national tient à
l'amour de sa patrie et on aime sa
patrie
100 m haies - ou encore moins mépriser
celle des hôtes et l'on veut que les
autres nous considèrent comme leurs
égaux
de penser à lui de penser à toutes ces
réalisations de penser ce que j'ai
appelé la puissance de ses convictions
c'est un homme qui n'a jamais douté et
je pense que il a été d'une loyauté
exceptionnelle à l'endroit de ses
convictions et ça nous donne justement
aujourd'hui l'occasion de se remémorer
et puis aussi deux insisté sur le fait
que c'est important d'avoir cette
continuité dans ses sentiments à sa
sensibilité et monsieur landry à cet
égard leur n'y a pas fait exception
ça l'avait beaucoup énergisé à devoir
arrive à la tête du parti québécois
s'est passé à 100% derrière vous j'ai
toujours eu de très bonnes relations
avec monsieur landry d'ailleurs il ya
quelques collègues qui m'ont envoyé des
photos récemment parce qu'évidemment
vous fait vous en doutez donc la banque
de photos est importante et je me suis
de ce voyage que nous avions fait cette
émission économique au chili et donc
c'était l'époque de l'épanouissement de
la bulle internet et puis donc on sait
fort bien que monsieur landry était
toujours plongé dans la modernité tout
en étant évidemment aussi d'un homme
d'une grande érudition investi de façon
massive dans le développement des
nouvelles technologies il était alors de
cette volonté de s'investir encore
davantage des métiers porteurs donc il a
réussi on a vu qu est ce que la cité du
multimédia et de ces éléments ont pu
apporter justement le dernier thé ici au
québec
alors on voit des images de l'intérieur
de l'église le gitan gouverneur michel
doyon vient tout juste d'arriver se
rendant directement à l'intérieur la
garde d'honneur qui se déplacent pour le
moment on la reverra un petit peu plus
tard ce sont des dossiers des policiers
de la sûreté du québec
en attendant monsieur péladeau on ne
peut pas oublier le fait qu'il l'a sans
doute influent ancien monsieur péladeau
à faire le saut en politique lors de la
campagne électorale de 2012 où il très
probablement il y en a beaucoup madame
marois aussi était fait une cour assidue
si je peux dire à monsieur péladeau à ce
moment là tous les souverainistes voyait
dans monsieur péladeau la façon de
relancer sans et surtout de sécuriser
les québécois se disait monsieur
péladeau les gens vont des as tu un
homme d'affaires qui a réussi ici nous
dit que la souveraineté c'est payant ils
vont croire et si c'était seul
essentiellement la raison pour laquelle
on est allé chercher monsieur péladeau
bon on ne saura jamais ce que ça va
donner mais je suis convaincu que
monsieur landry penser exactement la
même chose et orgue et à la caution
économique qui met que le parti
québécois recherchent depuis ses années
avec jacques parizeau et bernard landry
pierre karl péladeau s'inscrivait dans
cette île on y produit un gouvernement
dans plusieurs transactions
quand j'étais à la caisse de dépôt et ça
a toujours été un homme qui respecte et
le québec y était très rigoureux qui
s'intéressait beaucoup à l'économie qui
croyaient que les québécois pourra
accéder à l'indépendance devait
maîtriser leur leur économie leur
entreprise est dans un parti
d'intellectuels quelqu'un qui
s'intéressait comme ça à la réalité des
dollars et des cents à quand même
remarquable et au moment de la
transaction de vidéotron je suis allé
chez lui à verchères et au début il
était contre il voulait que il pensait
que rageuse de vache tv autres ont gelé
convaincu et finalement il a accepté que
vidéotron soit avec quebecor pour le
meilleur ou pour le pire mais
ça a toujours été un homme qui voulait
la croissance économique du québec qui
fait pas dogmatique ita très pratique on
annoncera aujourd'hui si on n'avait pas
eu bernard ben moi je pense que québec
ne serait pas une force économique comme
il l'est avec des entreprises
multinationales avec des entreprises
comme le régime d'épargne-actions qui il
a été avec monsieur parizeau et les jeux
vidéos on en a beaucoup parlé mais
c'était un homme qui croyait que les
québécois pour s'affirmer sur le plan
international doivent avoir une maîtrise
de l'économie
j'étais j'ai visité des compagnies
chilienne avec lui et il était fier de
dire aux au chilien que le québec c'est
quelque chose d'important sur le plan
économique il faut être ouvert au monde
global si t'as pas une nationalisme
patriotique raffermir c'est un
nationaliste global ouvert mondiale et
dans ce contexte l'or je pense que il ya
donné le ton à une nouvelle approche qui
était pas le lot de tous ses collègues
et qui était beaucoup plus québec aux
québécois alors que lui le marché
mondial les québécois sont capables
saisir quand on est capable de réussir
c'est pas parce qu'on s'appelle tremblay
gagnon qu'on peut pas réussir ce plan
mondial
julien lavoie alors monsieur nadeau
résume bien l'apport économique de
menaces qui disait par rapport à
d'autres de ses collègues c'est que
monsieur landry s'est toujours présentée
et je pense qu'il le pensait vraiment
comme un social démocrate mais c'est un
social-démocrate économique qui alors
qu'il y avait beaucoup de ses collègues
qui étaient beaucoup plus porté vers les
programmes sociaux et qui trouvaient
toujours que le gouvernement a été trop
sympathique envers les cas monsieur
landais en particulier à revers les gens
d'affaires et une dixième sauf erreur
que pour redistribuer la richesse
fallait la crise on voit le lieutenant
gouverneur qui fait son entrée
madame chantal renaud devraient suivre
incessamment vert melon un petit peu de
retard 4 5 minutes dans quelques dans
quelques instants plus continuer sauver
c'est donc avec cet aspect social ou
progressiste monsieur henry savait qu'il
fallait financer ces programmes se
soulèvent d'une certaine façon donc
créer la richesse des sites et de vision
économique donc ils avaient qui sous
tendait son progressisme social et
gouvernance a donné lieu à des des bras
de fer a cédé sinon assez dure au sein
du gouvernement sur le salaire minimum
d'équité salariale c'est qu'on voit les
premiers ministres se faire l'accolade
comme vous et tout à l'heure ils font
partie de ce grand cercle beaucoup
depuis peu d'élus avait que quelques uns
des premiers ministres qui peuvent
prétendre à cette situation contraint
nombreux on voit que c'est assez
chaleureux à monsieur bouchard monsieur
charest et ses rares les gens qui ont
passé par les mêmes expériences ce
niveau-là ça crée une espèce de
solidarité là au delà de la partisanerie
hélas oui permettez moi avant bernard
landry dit premier ministre eut droit à
des funérailles d'état maurice duplessis
en 59 daniel johnson en 68
jean jacques bertrand 73 jean lesage en
81 rené lévesque en 87
robert bourassa en 96 et jacques pas eu
besoin d'une maquette si le flux d'air
est intense d'état sont réservés mes
premiers - soit la fois dehors d'une
exception des ministres ayant droit
aussi pierre laporte
une ambition commune entre 106 et
girardi lévesque en 1993 on voit l image
madame harel avec son compagnon monsieur
urbain mais madame harel va prendre la
parole tout à l'heure et elle ira
certainement dans le sens dont vous
parlez sébastien l'importance des
programmes sociaux parce que dans ce
gouvernement là avec bernard landry
avait sur elle une période elle était
président l'assemblée nationale mais
dans les gouvernements du parti
québécois
elle incarne sans doute c'est elle un
peu plus à gauche qui défende est
peut-être madame marois aussi la
question des dcp 12.3 oui le terme voix
gilles déry aussi le gouvernement
lévesque un monsieur larry et au
développement économique
il y avait un espace de goût
député le contact et je pense le club
des onze qui était qui qui qui me
demandait mené presque une fronde contre
contre le gouvernement et contre lui
jacques parizeau parce que on lui
reprochait de ne pas être suffisamment
sociales entraînées souvenirs et c'est
clair que pour moi tout le travail qu'il
a fait dans le cas de la paix des braves
nous enseigne beaucoup sur comment on
doit continuer à faire le travail qui
est première nation alors c'est dans cet
esprit là qu'aujourd'hui mais pas
seulement ça vous comprendrez mais
qu'aujourd'hui de façon particulière on
est là pour eux pour monsieur landry
nadeau-dubois un grand homme qui a
marqué l'histoire du québec un homme qui
fait partie de la génération des
bâtisseurs et au québec dans les
dernières années on a eu beaucoup de
dirigeants qui ont déconstruit monsieur
landry fait partie de la génération des
gens qui ont construit le québec
alors on est très très content d'être
ici aujourd'hui et puis je peux voir pas
chez aussi de me rappeler que c'est un
homme qui a commencé son parcours dans
le mouvement étudiant
comme beaucoup de gens qui ont marqué
l'histoire du québec alors c'est
peut-être une petite petit clin d'oeil
que jamais j'ai envie de les lui faire
aujourd'hui
alors d'abord le souvenir de militants
qui a fait partout pas juste dans les
grandes assemblées parce que je les
fréquente et ces mêmes milieux là mais
aussi quelques semaines après l'élection
de 2003 j'étais le porte parole de l'ump
ils m'ont invité
il m'a traitée en homme politique alors
que j'étais juste le simple député d'un
petit parti de quelques centaines de
militants pour faire des propositions de
collaboration tout seul avec respect
avec gentillesse et je garderai donc le
souvenir d'un homme qui était accessible
et son sa fonction de premier ministre
ne le mettez pas à part des citoyens
alors c'est sans doute l'arrivée de la
famille madame reno accompagner des
enfants
selon jaime trois enfants julie l'aîné
filet pour milieu et parce qu'un qu'on a
vu un peu ces derniers jours qui prenait
la parole devant les médias alors madame
reno qui mariait monsieur landré depuis
le médium 2004 mais paul alors les
enfants qu aucune me saoule induit
beaucoup beaucoup d'amour c'est pascal
d'ailleurs qui va prendre la parole
julian
julia gauche pascal qui tient la main de
madame reno et philippe sur la droite
l'harmonie familiale comptait beaucoup
pour monsieur landry qu'en lorraine
laporte est morte en 1999 donc sa
première femme
j'ai perdu une raison de rentrer à la
maison il était très attaché à cette
maison là où est sa maison à sa vie
familiale et quand madame reno est
rentré dans sa vie il a retrouvé ce
corps là d'une certaine façon on attend
lutte loches qui vendre devrait sonner
jusqu'à l'arrivée du cercueil par la
suite de monseigneur christian lépine il
madame run où il fait très présente je
me suis de la campagne de 2003 celle qui
a été immortalisée par jean claude
labrecque chantal était toujours là pour
vous pour appuyer son mari le cercle y
fait son entrée porté par des officiers
de la sûreté du québec drapeau du québec
qui orne le cercueil qui sera remis à la
fin de la cérémonie al famille ainsi que
les décorations de monsieur landry au
cours des années parce qu'il a reçu de
nombreuses décorations leur grand
recueillement dans la basilique
notre-dame
[Musique]
les gens de mon pays ce sens gens de
parole et jean de causerie qui parle
pour s'entendre il parle pour parler il
faut les écouter c'est parfois vérité et
c'est parfois mensonge mais la plupart
du temps c'est le bonheur qui dit comme
il faudra de temps pour saisir le
bonheur à travers la misère en maille et
au plaisir temps d'en rêver tous vos que
d'en parler à l'aise
poland mon pays je vous entends parler
et j'en ai danse au pied et musique aux
oreilles et du loing en plus loin de
ceux neigeux d'isère où vous vous
entêtez à jeter beau village
je vous répéterai pourparlers et beau
dire on proposé par l'ue jusqu'à perdre
mon nom aux voix tant écouter pour qu'il
ne reste plus de moi même qu'un peu gros
traits corse au nord je vous autant
jaser sur les perrons des portes et de
chaque côté néo créons des clôtures je
vous entend chanter dans mad mise
notre trop court et et démons hiver si
longue
je vous entends rêvait dans les soirs de
doute ans il est question de vente vente
de gréement de l'amour infini d'espoir
et de récolte d'amour et du voisin qui
veut marier sa fille voit noir le bois
dur si des corses et de cordages voit le
pays plein champ et voit les amoureux
d'où ce bois attendri des amours du
village webos anciens dans son champ lui
en ville
pay as you read écoles et palabres et
sparages magasin général et resto du
coin les pans les quais l'égard de vos
crimes maritime
taye m'apprenait très m'arrache
l'oreille est ce vous que j'appelle vous
qui m'appelait langage de mon père est
pas toi 17e en fait ce voyage mal et
mélancolie vous fait plaisir il sagesse
folie il n'est coins de la terre où je
ne vous entendent il est né coin de ma
vie à l'abri de bruit ils n'échangent de
moi qui ne souhaite tout faire avec pour
mon bon port avec votre musique
[Musique]
je vous entends rêver douche comme
rivière
je vous entends claqué comme voile du
lard
monde et comme je t'aime
je vous entends rouler comme pas
j'entends temps de paix comme un cours
de 4 euros
cognet commun
je vous entends pas c'est comme un
glaçon des banques je vous en
les ibères
[Musique]
en
où
[Musique]
au nom du père et du fils et du
saint-esprit le seigneur soit avec vous
et avec votre esprit nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui dans cette église pour
entourer de notre réflexion de notre
sympathie de notre amitié
ceux et celles qui sont dans la peine ce
pass partiellement madame chantal renaud
est posée bernard landry le ministre du
québec ainsi qu'à ses enfants julie
philippe et pascal à ses petits enfants
de toute leur famille ainsi qu'aux
nombreux amis et collègues de bernard
landry
je veux particulièrement salué la
présence de votre honneur monsieur le
lieutenant gouverneur
je suis le premier ministre du québec
madame et monsieur le premier ministre
et madame lisette lapointe mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires et élus
municipaux
messieurs les représentants des
premières nations
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
étrangers et distingués invités
nous voulons affirmer ensemble que tout
s'est lié d'amitié d'affection que nous
tissons tout au long de notre vie ne
savait pas avec la mort mais ont un
avenir dans l'éternité
tournons nous vers le christ avec
confiance en reconnaissant notre
faiblesse et ouvrons notre coeur à la
miséricorde de dieu
[Musique]
que dieu tout puissant nous fasse
miséricorde qui nous pardonne nos péchés
et nous conduisent à la vie éternelle
seigneur jésus tu a permis que celui là
même qui vient de nous quitter
soit aujourd'hui celui qui nous
rassemble nous étions dispersés par
notre travail et nos occupations
voici que nous les avons laissés pour
nous unir à la peine d autres survécu
toi-même notre condition humaine notre
condition d'homme ouvre nos coeurs à la
lumière de ton message aux témoignages
de ton amour pour tous les êtres humains
conduit nous ici plus près de bernard
plus près de toi qui est vivant
aujourd'hui et pour les siècles des
siècles avant de poursuivre la
célébration liturgique j'invite monsieur
jean yves duthel un ami de la famille
pour la partie des témoignages veuillez
vous asseoir
chers amis il nous a quittés au soir de
sa vie aimer et en admire et il a voulu
que vous soyez ici présents en cette
terre qu'il chérissait en ce pays
inachevé
bernard landry dit avec gaston miron
ça ne pourra pas toujours ne pas arriver
nous entrerons là on nous sommes déjà
car il n'est pas question de laisser
tomber notre espérance célébrons cet
homme
inlassable et remarquable qu'il fût
qu'il est et restera je lui dois de
préciser ceci il a scénarisé chaque
seconde de ses funérailles
j'invite maintenant sa fille pascale à
venir ou pas mais
au nom de toute la famille je veux
d'abord remercier les gens du québec et
des autres nations qui par milliers nous
ont témoigné au cours des derniers jours
leur sympathie leur affection et leur
respect pour papa et son oeuvre
nous en avons tous été très touché vous
nous avez apporté beaucoup de réconfort
et papa on aurait été profondément
heureux on nous demande souvent ce que
c'est que d'être les enfants de bernard
landry
si pas banale bien sûr enfin il nous
vous racontais des histoires qui nous
emmener au camping solaire nous emmener
en gaspésie comme les autres papas mais
pas vraiment comme tous les autres papas
petit peu de mes amis chanter avec moi
el pueblo unido jamas sera vencido le
peuple uni jamais ne sera vaincu
et j'étais déjà adulte lorsque j'ai
appris que les vraies paroles de la
chanson de nicolas et bart n'était pas
maintenant riel et chénier vous vivez au
fond de nos coeurs peu d'amis aussi
avait un papa qui roulait en citroën ds
en pestant les gitanes en chantant à tue
tête du brassens reliquat de son séjour
en europe
puis il y eut 1976 on se voyait moins
bien sûr mais nous les enfants avons
vécu des moments exceptionnels ils nous
emmenaient partout des assemblées de
cuisine des réunions de militants des
débats avec des adversaires
papa tu es qu'en politique il n'ya pas
d'ennemis il n'y a que des adversaires
des repas animé avec des esprits
brillants aucune porte ne nous était
fermé il tenait à ce que nous soyons
instruits et éduqués
il nous a exposé à sa grande culture à
son amour du français et de la
civilisation qui le portent au respect
de son prochain à son combat sans répit
pour ses idéaux a une manière d'être
citoyen vous imaginez sûrement ce que
c'est qu'être nadeau au restaurant avec
mon père qui fait une scène pour être
servis en français
ado c'est très dur mais c'est très
formateur
on apprend que parfois pour changer les
choses il faut monter au front il faut
savoir mener des batailles même
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas populaires
il avait d'ailleurs eu le courage de
redéfinir avec ses collègues du parti
québécois
la notion même de ce qu'est une famille
leur refonte du code civil a permis à ma
soeur julie d'être reconnue comme la
mère des deux enfants qu'elle a eus avec
sa compagne papa était un homme
rigoureux avec tout ce que ça implique
comme ce soir où ma soeur mon frère et
moi nous étions dans la jeune vingtaine
et ils nous avaient vertement engueuler
au souper du dimanche il avait même
quitté la table quand il a su que nous
n'étions pas allés voter aux élections
municipales scolaires
j'ai les landry les attentes étaient
toujours haute puis verchères là où est
née sa gran paternité avec le baptême de
camille à l'été 87
ma mère et mon père ont ouvert leur
maison grande comme leur coeur avec
chaque nouvel enfant pape a rajouté une
place pour dormir et le grand-papa
chantait des chansons il préparait des
feux de foyer et se laissait maquiller
ils organisaient des feux d'artifice
bonne nuit princes et princesses de la
lièvre et du saint-laurent
voilà comment mon père quittait ses
petits enfants en leur rappelant leurs
racines avant de les envoyer dormir papa
nous aimaient réunis avec cette maison
il a permis à la famille élargie de
nouer des liens qui ne se brise on
jamais puis à table il y eut des chaises
vides
nous avons souffert ensemble mais les
repas en reprit les vives conversations
aussi les événements de chacun mais
débat sur l'actualité et souvenirs de
jeunesse les anecdotes de saint jacques
les blagues il aimait se mettre en scène
et autour de la table de nouveaux
visages ajoutant chacun sa couleur son
histoire son avenir tissé dans le nôtre
nous avons été vraiment choyés avec nos
rapporté papa était très fier de notre
famille métissée serré qui représente ce
que le québec devient papa est également
très fier d'avoir eu la chance d'être
accompagné par trois femmes
exceptionnelles
sa mère thérèse lorraine notre mère et
notre chère chantal elles sont toutes
les trois certainement une des sources
de sa grandeur lors de notre dernier
souper de famille il a porté un toast le
vent notre verre à la famille et à la
patrie
il n'y a rien de plus important au coeur
de sa vie ces deux thèmes la patrie et
la famille quand on y pense il ne s'agit
au fond que d'un seul il avait la preuve
en fonte
miction que la patrie et la famille
rassemble toutes les deux des gens qui
partagent une histoire des valeurs et
qui chaque jour décide de la nouvelle
page du livre qu'ils vont écrire
ensemble pour lui à quelque échelle que
ce soit les forts doivent protéger les
faibles
aux échecs et à l'adversité
à quelle que soit l'échelle il faut
vivre ensemble les départs qui nous
attriste et les arrivées qui nous
renforcent notre père est éternel et
vivra toujours dans les gestes les
décisions les combats et les bonheurs de
chantal julie caroline philippe josé
pascal maxime camille gabriel marguerite
clémentine elle si jules robin médéric
matteo flavie sacha nouveau bébé qui
arrivera dans deux mois et tous leurs
descendants en terminant plus que tous
les hommages ce qui le rendrait heureux
c'est que vous tous à votre manière
continuer son combat pour un québec plus
juste plus fort plus libre merci
ses pairs ont voulu lui rendre hommage
mesdames et messieurs le premier
ministre du québec monsieur françois le
groupe
chantal julie philippe pascal
monseigneur ou pin
mesdames messieurs les premiers
ministres madame lapointe chat collègues
parlementaires élus municipaux
messieurs les représentants des
premières nations mesdames messieurs des
représentants étrangers
c'est un des invités comme beaucoup de
québécois
c'est avec beaucoup de tristesse que
j'ai appris le décès de bernard landry
je lui avais parlé quelques jours plus
tôt et on s'était promis de se voir dans
les prochains jours monsieur landry
m'avait dit qu'il voulait m'aider à
remplir ma tâche
malgré nos différends ça montre la
hauteur et le sens du devoir de cet
homme d'exception
aujourd'hui on est tous réunis pour
saluer le départ d'un grand patriote
pour utiliser un mot qu'il aimait
tellement dans nos rangs dry a été un
grand serviteur de l'état mais surtout
un grand serviteur de la nation
québécoise cette nation son peuple
il l'a aimée de toutes ses forces il l'a
défendu avec fougue avec passion avec
panache jusqu'à son dernier souffle
bernard landry s'est investi dans la pi
dans la vie politique et publique pour
voir le québec s'épanouir pour voir le
québec prendre sa place dans mon jeu
landry et mais se dire avant tout un
militant
mais il était tellement plus il a été un
des grands bâtisseurs du québec moderne
jeune souvenir de lui
d'abord communiste de l'économie et des
finances j'étais tellement impressionné
par sa connaissance de l'économie du
québec faisait qu'une bonne partie de la
politique économique du québec a été
pensé et conçu par louis
mais ce n'était pas seulement un homme
de conseils je les ai vus négocié des
ententes avec des entrepreneurs pour
faire aboutir concrètement des
investissements au québec
il a été un promoteur infatigable du
développement économique du québec
c'est lui qui a posé les fondations de
notre industrie numérique
il comprenait l'importance pour nos
entreprises de l'innovation de soucis
encourager une culture de
l'entrepreneuriat au québec et ses
ambitions dépassent largement les
frontières du québec
on doit pas oublier ses efforts de
promotion du commerce international
il combat qu'il a mené pour le libre
échange à la fin des années 80
sa passion pour le développement
économique du québec va toujours rester
pour moi une grande source d'inspiration
monsieur landry était un homme
profondément responsable un homme
capable de mettre en place des
programmes sociaux pour les plus démunis
mais capable aussi d'une grande rigueur
fiscale
l'auto jours d'ailleurs refusé d
étiquette de droite ou de gauche
je me souviens aussi de bernard landry
comme d'un premier ministre qui a marqué
l'histoire
il a négocié la paix des braves une
entente avec le peuple crie fondé sur la
confiance et le respect mutuel un traité
historique une première entre un état et
nation autochtone une contribution
exceptionnelle à la paternité en open ce
landry était aussi un orateur
exceptionnel qui avaient toutes un sens
de la répartie me rappelle
des périodes de questions lorsqu'on
était au gouvernement qu'une question
adressée à monsieur landry on se
regardait tous constitués le position va
manger tout seul mais derrière l'homme
des temps il y avait cet homme attachant
mais s'il y avait un exemplaire par sa
classe par son érudition par sa grande
curiosité intellectuelle par son
ouverture à tout ce qui est humain il a
élevé et enrichit nos dépens on va
jamais assez souligner sa générosité il
disait le parti avant les hommes et la
patrie et vente partie sages conseils
que je vais pas oublier monsieur landry
donc les accomplissements ce grand
bâtisseur du québec n'ont pas fini de se
faire sentir son héritage va s'inscrire
dans la durée
il va rester gravé dans nos mémoires de
sa maison sur les rives du saint laurent
il nous a inspirés jusqu'à la fin chaque
chantal merci d'avoir permis à monsieur
landry passé ses derniers moments à la
maison je sais que tu es nuit on était
côte au cours des derniers mois merci
chers membres de la famille proche de
bernard landry cher québécois je vous
offre au nom du gouverneur
du québec mes plus sincères condoléances
oui les québécois font quelque chose
comme un grand peuple et bernard landry
aura été à la hauteur de ce peuple qu'il
a aimée
si passionnément merci monsieur landry
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaud
oh
pour eux
ici
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
où
oh
ou si vous
et
[Musique]
vous
nous
[Musique]
or
oh
[Musique]
et
mesdames et messieurs
le premier ministre monsieur jean
charest
madame reno membres de la famille et
amis de monsieur landry excellence
monseigneur lépine votre honneur
monsieur le lieutenant gouverneur sur le
premier ministre du québec et madame
madame le problème à nice ma voix et
messieurs du premier ministre et madame
lapointe saint-ghislain éviter en
politique le premier ministre landry -
étions au sens le plus noble du terme
des adversaires à l'assemblée nationale
du québec nous étions assis l'un en face
de l'autre
la tradition parlementaire voulant que
les chefs des partis soient séparés par
la distance de deux épées tendu qui ne
se toucheront jamais cela symbolise le
renoncement la force ainsi que
l'engagement du peuple québécois et de
ses élus envers la démocratie et la
règle de droit
j'ai d'abord été son chef de
l'opposition officielle et lui mon
premier ministre les rôles
se sont inversés nos convictions sur
certains enjeux et s y opposer qu'elle
n'allait jamais se rencontrer pendant
toutes ces vies le premier ministre
andri a été habitée par une profonde
conviction celle de l'indépendance du
québec
je ne connais aucune autre personne pour
qui cette conviction était aussi ancrée
dans chaque dimension de sa vie il
s'était fixé une mission et dans ce
combat il ne jamais prix ne serait ce
qu'une seule journée de congé
sa passion pour le québec s'est traduite
par une passion pour notre économie en
particulier en 1979 il nous a livré une
vision de notre avenir intitulé bâtir le
québec qué les structures et les
politiques des gouvernements ou
plusieurs années à venir il nous guidera
vers l'équilibré budgétaire et par le
développement du multimédia
il ajoutera une dimension à l'économie
de notre métropole
il participe au débat sur le
libre-échange ou des élections générales
de 1988
là où on ne l'attendait pas et sa voix à
porter et contribuer à faire avancer une
politique qui est importante pour
l'avenir du québec
la paix des braves
consacre l'oeuvre d'une vie avec le
peuple crie négocié la nation à nation
et avec les mains tendues vers le grand
chef l'écrivent les critères moses ils
jouent ensemble d'époque au
développement du nord québécois
la vie politique ces exigences de
jugement de l'actualité peut être
impitoyable et parfois sans appel c'est
dans la durée que nous pouvons le mieux
mesurer le poids des responsabilités
la portée des risques des choix et des
décisions pour le jugement de l'histoire
de ta sera un bon témoin un allié pour
le premier ministre landry des amis
communs me tenais informé de son état de
santé
nous nous sommes parlé il ya une dizaine
de jours avant son décès notre
conversation était très chaleureuse et
elle m'a beaucoup ému j'avais enfin
l'occasion de lui dire que nous pensions
beaucoup réduit à son épouse chantal et
à sa famille
j'ai pu lui dire
qu'il devait être très fier de tout ce
qu'il avait accompli pour le québec
là où se trouvait autrefois un
adversaire
j'ai reconnu un homme dont le coeur
déborde d'amour pour le québec auquel il
aura consacré plus de 50 ans de sa vie
un homme pour qui tous les québécois
sans exception témoigne aujourd'hui le
plus grand respect
j'habite maintenant le premier ministre
monsieur lucien bouchard amis de
monsieur landry à vous adresser la
parole
chantal julie philippe pascal membres de
la famille monsieur le premier ministre
djinnit terre mesdames et messieurs
chers amis et bernard landry avait à
peine 20 ans au début des années 60 à
partir de là son destin devait se fondre
dans la suite de jésus années
précédentes où s'est construit le québec
ce fut une heureuse rencontre que celle
de ce jeune homme au regard des perdants
avec une société tendue vers la
mobilisation de ses forces vives si
longtemps contenue il ne s'agissait pas
moins que d'ouvrir les vannes d'une
refondation collective il fallait
repenser les missions éducatives et
sociales
si tu veux la culture au sens de la
démarche mettre en place les leviers du
développement économique
en plus de se donner un état et des
institutions efficaces et démocratique
un immense chantier allait s'ouvrir
on aurait besoin de bras de cerveau de
connaissances et de courage on aurait
besoin d'un homme de feu comme bernard
landry car il faudrait des inspirateurs
de peuples on chez que les québec pu
compter sur des leaders inspirants au
moment charnière de son histoire le
canada tout entier
puis-je a d'ailleurs abondamment dans la
même source notre révolution tranquille
eu la même chance
les grands disparus qui à la tête de nos
gouvernements ont guidé et soutenu cet
effort collectif ont droit à notre
reconnaissance salon
jean le chef daniel johnson robert
bourassa en dévers et jacques parizeau
c'est l'honneur de bernard landry ne se
joindre aujourd'hui cette éminente
croate
il ne partageait pas tous les mêmes
opinions
il ne craignait pas d'en débattre ce qui
ne les a pas empêchés de travailler
chacun à sa façon
mais selon son idéal à l'éducation d'une
société à l'édification d'une société
résolument moderne démocratique et
solidaire
en particulier ils n'avaient pas la même
conception des chemins que doit
emprunter l'avenir du québec à cet égard
ce n'est pas le moindre des travailleurs
méritent que d'avoir su respecter en
tout temps la volonté de leurs
concitoyens sans doute n'ont-ils pas été
exempt d'erreurs
ni même de défaillance comme vais
peut-être davantage gouverneur a connu
la cruelle séquence des déboires succès
dans vos rares exaltation mais ils ont
en commun d'avoir consacré leur vie
durant le meilleur d'eux mêmes à nous
transmettre le riche héritage dont nous
bénéficions commencé veille la vocation
politique d'un jeune homme que bernard
élevé dans une famille modeste c'est une
région rurale des années 40 et 50
la prise de conscience de son talent et
de l'influencé les gens c'est autour de
lui a certainement nourri très tôt de
légitimes ambitions
bernard s'est lui même ce qu'il devait
aux perspectives universel que lui
ouvrit sa formation classique au
séminaire de joliette a par son
engagement souverainiste
rien ne compta autant pour lui que ces
lectures littéraires
saurik en vérité il a été façonné par sa
passion pour l'histoire tout entretien
le moindrement sérieux chez maillet de
références anciennes et contemporaines
je suis même demandé parfois s'il
n'avait pas comme napoléon fait son
livre de chevet des vies parallèles
depuis tard il pouvait donner
l'impression de voir l'histoire du
québec comme une épopée dans le
prolongement des grands moments de
l'histoire de france
les orateurs fameux velay sa
conversation l'art de l'éloquence et de
la parole il était sa grande affaire
vous pensez bien que l'évocation des
ritter de l'antiquité d'un ailier au
passage quelques citations latines
plus près de nous le manceau j'aurais
israeli churchill lui joseph papineau
on ne remercie compter parmi ses héros
les grandes ombres du passé habitait la
mémoire l'épisode telle imagination de
bernard qui lui reprochera d'avoir voulu
marcher sur les crêtes et de nourrir
pour le québec
une ambition à la mesure de ses rêves à
notre dernier déjeuner nous nous sommes
rappelés notre commune admiration pour
le célèbre discours d'henri bourassa au
congrès eucharistique international de
1910 possiblement le plus émouvant et le
projet d'autres cas jamais prononcée par
un québécois bernard qui j'avais toute
notre histoire connaissait quasiment par
coeur
la narration de ce moment munich fait
par le chanoine groulx présent de cette
basilique l' on ne peut pas ne pas
éprouver une certaine émotion à l'idée
de se trouver en ce moment à
l'endroit-même douche et alors ils
veulent la grande voix d'henri bourassa
en présence de wilfrid laurier de lomer
gouin et du personal légat du pape
wurz a exprimé avec force les zinnias
sion que lui inspirait le projet des
plus hautes instances du thé gestique de
faire de l'anglais la langue fonctionnel
d'olivier shenzhen il est impossible de
décrire l'entousiasme et à leur survie
les centaines d'éveil francophones et
les milliers de personnes assises ou
debout qui emplissait cette basilique
est débordé sur l'esplanade de la place
d'armes
ils tournaient donc parfaitement que ce
soit célébré ici dans ces lieux
historiques
les funérailles de cet irréductible et
défenseur de la langue française
c'a été bernard landry pour employer une
expression qui lui étaient familières
dernière avait le projet souverainiste
chevillée au coeur
il en fut un militant de la première
heure payant poursuivi la réalisation en
discussion au dernier souffle
aucune déconvenues électorales ou
référendaire latéral jamais sa
motivation il tue quand d'autres en
octobre 1995 à percevoir la terre
promise mais s'il regrettait la décision
populaire il ne la remet jamais en cause
l'amertume n'avait pas prise sur cet
éternel optimiste je devais penser que
comme rené lévesque et jacques parizeau
il était démocrate avant d'être
souverainiste et que pour lui rien ne
peut se substituer son jugement ne peut
substituer son jugement à celui du
peuple non plus que le blâme étiez choix
qu'ils aient souffert de voir une achevé
la cause de sa vie ne laisse pas de
doute ce connaisseur de l'histoire
ce sera probablement dié qu'une fois
joué son rôle d'inspirateur il devait
s'en remettre pour la suite des choses
aux générations montantes d'avenir
on peut le préparer mais ils savent ce
que voudront en faire ce qu'ils nous
suivent
devant ce dessin qui vient de s'achever
il convient de s'incliner avec le
respect dû à un homme d'honneur et les
convictions infidèle et valeureux
combattants on a mis bon ordre
[Applaudissements]
bernard landry a aussi voulu que soient
présents aujourd'hui celui avec lequel
de nation à nation il a négocié puis
signé la paix des braves
mesdames et messieurs d'anciens chefs la
nation crie monsieur tête rousse
[Applaudissements]
moi je jouis même nom se dire je chante
je veux na li de bernard landry
le premier ministre du québec et
mesdames et messieurs le premier
ministre landry est un ami des cris il
est également mon ami il m'a même appelé
son frère
après les années 90 cette décennie de
divergences sur la vue
quant au développement de la baie james
il devenait évident que quelque chose
devait changer et ce changement est
survenu avec le premier ministre bernard
landry en 2001 il était temps de mettre
de côté dans ces conflits
le problème a été la loi serait vu comme
étant mis de côté face au développement
entre 75 avec la signature de l'entente
et 2001 les promesses y réaliser du
québec comme du canada avait augmenté en
conséquence le premier ministre landry
était un homme qui savait que l'avenir
de tout peuple qu'il soit québécois où
le peuple crie était avant tout
déterminé par le développement
économique est nous avons tous les deux
compris qu'il était mieux de voir de
manière positive l'avenir et 2
cherchez des réalisations où nous
pouvions en profiter les deux et en être
fier en 2001 j'ai eu ma première
rencontre avec lui
deux mois après qu'il avait pris le
pouvoir
une des questions qu'il m'a posée était
vraiment intéressante et sam sam avait
intrigué il m'a dit grand chef qui
êtes-vous avant tout être vous un
keynésien en tout ou en québécois
alors j'ai fait mille kilomètres dans
mon cerveau pour traverser l'océan pour
essayer de chercher la réponse est
finalement j'ai trouvé dix lits en
premier un canadien né en premier à
québécois je suis et où cela veut dire
des peuples et peuple dans le droit
international
les peuples ont le droit de
l'autodétermination ils me regardent
avec un sourire et le moisi
nous nous rencontrerons à nouveau et
cela fut et c'est en 2001 il était temps
de refonder notre relation est nouveau
partenariat est né
cette entente connu maintenant comme est
un d'appel épreuve a été signé en
février 2002 et c'était le premier
ministre landry qui a eu la prévoyance
et le courage de mettre de côté des
scissions du passé et de fonder nouvelle
relation avec le peuple crie et cela
apporte aux fruits encore aujourd'hui et
nous espérons en recueillir les fruits
pour des longues années l'accord de la
paix les brèves du pav a été fondée dans
notre désir partagé 2
voir nous pablo prospérer et cela motive
encore le développement dans la baie
james
il y a plus de développement aujourd'hui
qu'à tout moment de notre histoire
les mines les forêts le développement
communautaire et bien sûr l'hydro
électricité continuent d'être vraiment
au coeur de la prospérité du
développement québécois nous partageons
tout ce qui a été rendu possible par ce
grand homme qui ici devant lui la
nouvelle prospérité de la région fondée
sur le développement est maintenant
partager de façon appropriée or tous les
parties prenantes nice territoire tous
les enjeux n'ont pas été réglés mais
grâce à l'intervention de pendant landry
nous avons maintenant les moyens de
s'assurer un avenir prospère pour nous
bernard landry était un homme doué de
charme et d'intelligence et il avait
vraiment un courage profond et une
vision de l'avenir
je suis fier d'avoir connu et je suis
fier d'avoir soutenu
je suis parti tellement fier d'avoir pu
l'appeler un ami et même un frère
c'est avec grande tristesse que
j'aimerais exprimer mes condoléances à
la famille et tous les amis de bernard
landry
si nous sommes tristes aujourd'hui nous
devons également être reconnaissant que
nous avons eu le grand privilège de
l'avoir connu j'ai mieux vaut chemin
je veux dire mon dernier au revoir à mon
ami à mon frère bernard repose en paix
tu mérite un bon repos adieu bernard
les témoignages que vous entendrez
maintenant se feront tous au nom de
l'amitié et du respect deux valeurs
essentielles à monsieur l'indre
[Musique]
où
ni
[Musique]
bon
et
il
oui
[Musique]
i
non
et
[Musique]
mon
oh
[Musique]
et
on
oui
je
[Musique]
shi
et
g
[Musique]
chantage jeudi philippe
pascal tous les membres cette belle et
grande famille landri monseigneur votre
noble âme la première mine ce premier
ministre messieurs les premiers
ministres anciens collègues de
l'assemblée nationale chère et du
membres des premières nations à tous les
amis de bernard landry un pays depuis
les siècles qui l'ont précédé sur
l'étendue merveilleuse de notre planète
à protéger orientés dans cette quête
inaliénable du genre humain vers la
liberté
les milliards de citoyens nous entoure
en furent sa caution et son inspiration
pour le combat qu'il n'aura jamais
ralenti un pays
quoi de plus naturel
est inscrit dans le sens de l'histoire
que de vouloir s'en donnait 1 puisque
tous les hommes et les femmes ressentent
un jour un réel besoin de s'affranchir
et s'émanciper un pays
il savait qu'il devait se construire
avec ceux et celles qui sont venues de
gars comme de bretagne de la rochelle
pour fraterniser avec ceux et celles qui
se trouvaient sur ce territoire
celui des premières nations sont venus
les rejoindre pour les enrichir ceux du
vermont du massachusetts sont venus s'y
ajouter ceux de limerick d'edimbourg et
également ceux de londres
enrichie enrichir cette diversité
ils sont venus ensuite d'italie de grèce
ou encore de france et d'angleterre
ils viennent maintenant de saigon
d'haïti du maghreb du cameroun et tant
d'autres pays pour que nous puissions
persévérer dans la poursuite de
l'établissement d'une société plus libre
plus juste plus riche et plus généreuse
un pays
cette recherche de ce pays fut toujours
pour lui celle de l'ouverture de la joue
sous plus de l'excédent du supplément de
l'amitié de l' échange de l'addition
encore de la générosité de la mansuétude
et fondamentalement de la bonté ce pays
il a souhaité le faire pour tous et pour
toutes il a voulu le faire pour ceux et
celles qui nous ont précédés et qui
méritait de leur laisser comme
descendance le fruit de leurs efforts
historiques
il a voulu le faire pour ceux et celles
qui vont lui succéder pour que les
fruits des combats tiers puissent leur
permettre de continuer à s'épanouir et
trouver encore davantage d'autonomie et
de vivacité
il a voulu le faire pour tous les
citoyens et citoyennes du monde parce
qu'à juste titre il avait cet intime
conviction que les québécois les
québécoises pouvait et savez être en
mesure de proposer ces valeurs
universelles auxquelles il a l'air
depuis toujours il a voulu le faire
aussi pour ses amis quel qu'il soit
parce qu'ils savaient que le débat est
le gage de l'ouverture et du
développement l'a voulu le faire pour
tous ses compatriotes avec elle
s'enrichit ce au sens propre du terme
parce qu'ils étaient de pignons partagé
par beaucoup que l'assujettissement
pouvoir économique et financier
d'ailleurs ne pouvait que difficilement
mener à l'éducation à la connaissance et
donc à la liberté ce pays dont il voyait
l'arrivée de façon inéluctable ce pays
le sang intarissable de l'histoire du
pays qui conçut m
la recherche assidue de son temps ce
pays dont il a partagé la quête avec des
milliers d'autres en allant les voir et
les entendre ce pays votre pays monsieur
le premier ministre votre pays
monsieur lundi notre pays bernard nous
continuerons de vouloir sa réalisation
vous nous avez 10 ou 20 et nous nous en
souviendrons toujours notre fabuleux
québec doit choisir la liberté et la
dignité
notre pays monsieur emery
nous ne l'oublierons jamais tout comme
nous ne vous oublierons jamais merci
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
j
j'appelle son fidèle complice
universitaire le docteur en sciences
politiques à l'uqam le sujet françois
payet
madame chantal renaud chers membres de
la famille cher québécoise cher
québécois je redoutais ce moment où
j'allais devoir me présenter devant vous
pour parler de cet homme qui a ajouté sa
pierre à l'édifice de notre histoire et
qui a marqué nos vies en ne faisant
jamais l'économie de la sienne j'ai eu
le grand privilège d'enseigner avec le
professeur landry ces dernières années
en début de session
il commençait le court par cette phrase
vous avez quelque chose que je n'aurais
plus jamais c'est la jeunesse et j'ai
quelque chose que vous n'avez pas encore
mis qu'ils auraient un jour c'est
l'expérience et celle de mon devoir de
vous transmettre cette expérience
aujourd'hui ceux qui ont connu monsieur
landry savent à quel point il accordait
une grande place à la notion du devoir
pour cette raison jusqu'au printemps
dernier
il enseigne car il pensait qu'il était
de sa responsabilité de tendre la main
aux plus jeunes générations pour que
notre mémoire collective ne s'efface
jamais je me suis réveillé ce matin en
me disant que mon mentor et ami ne
verrait jamais son idéal se réaliser
bernard landry et mes temps évoqué
l'avenir parler du pays à bâtir
il ne coûtera pas aux fruits de cet
accomplissement lui qui a pourtant
abondamment ce mille projets de
l'indépendance les voix de boer co2 les
vins de paille qu'ils ont est
aujourd'hui celle de bernard landry se
sont éteints ne soyons pas trop triste
car elle résonne en chacun de nous
toutefois d'autres voies devront
s'élever au concert des nations
pour faire reconnaître celle du québec
j'entends le poète vignon me murmurer à
l'oreille
dans tout et b quoi un homme sommeille
il prétend qu'il veut sans lever le
doigt
moi je prétends qu'il dans faut que je
le réveil faut que je le réveil avant de
m'endormir
voilà l'héritage de bernard landry être
au service de son peuple pour qu'il se
réveille et qui s'accomplissent les
destiner les plus admirables ont été
celles de femmes et d'hommes qui ont
entretenu la passion qui les anime et
thérèse casgrain gandhi lucille teasdale
charles de gaulle rené lévesque ont
beaucoup vécu et se sont accomplis parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup aimé c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont pas hésité à mettre leur
vie au service de celles et de ceux
qu'ils aimaient que leurs vies sont
devenus des destinées réussi la carrière
politique et pédagogique de bernard
landry a été long et fructueuse rempli
de réalisation économique culturel
social et diplomatique
mais ce qui en fait une réelle réussite
c'est qu'il a été aimée des québécois
monsieur landry à aimer le peuple
québécois au point de lui consacrer sa
vie et en retour il a été aimé de son
peuple
parce qu'il était un homme d'état
entièrement dévoué à sa patrie nous
aurons souvent entendu bernard landry
dire la patrie avant le parti et le
parti avant les intérêts personnels
jusqu'à ses derniers instants
il en donnera l'exemple en demandant
aujourd'hui à trois premiers ministres
qui représente 3 biologie véhicules et
chez son peuple il aura jusqu'à la fin
placer les intérêts de la patrie au
dessus de la partisanerie il aura été
jusqu'à son dernier souffle un
rassembleur sur une note un peu plus
personnel
il ya quelques années aux funérailles
d'un autre de nos géants
monsieur jacques parizeau j'avais pris
monsieur landry a par après la cérémonie
pour lui dire je vous invite le québec a
encore besoin de vous j'ai encore besoin
de vous toucher
il m'avait répondu qu'il ferait son
possible en ajoutant c'est jean-françois
malgré les progrès de la médecine le
taux de mortalité chez l'être humain est
tojours de 100%
j'aime à penser que votre lumière nous
éclairera encore longtemps
merci pour ce bel héritage monsieur
landry
c'est notre devoir maintenant de
reprendre le flambeau reposez en paix
mon brave patriotes hier à notre cours
de gestion internationale vous nous avez
manqué monsieur le professeur
il était beaucoup plus jeunes comme cela
ne l'a rencontré pour la première fois
aujourd'hui
mais il n'avait pas la responsabilité
qu'il a maintenant monsieur pascal
pascal bérubé chef intérimaire du parti
québécois
chère chantal je diffusais pascal
membres de la famille et amis au nom de
la famille politique du premier ministre
landry
le parti québécois je suis ici avec vous
pour livrer un message d'espoir cet
espoir
toutes ces vies en témoigne c'est le
catalyseur de son action politique
il n'y a pas de geste plus fort n'y a
pas de juste qu'une autre que celui
qu'on fait pour sa patrie c'est
l'essentiel de ses enseignements c'est
ce qu'il a appliqué tous les jours de sa
vie il n'a jamais abandonné
il n'a jamais douté n'a jamais dévié
fidèle et loyal il souhaitait au plus
profond qu'un que chacun puisse aller au
bout de ses rêves qu aucun québécois ne
soit forcé de poser de limites à ses
ambitions il croyait aux régions du
québec
alors potentiel de développement il ya
l'importance de leur contribution
il connaissait la valeur de l'effort il
faisait confiance aux entrepreneurs
comme aux travailleurs pour tracer des
voies d'avenir
il savait que par les jeunes viennent
l'innovation le progrès et que notre
devoir est de faire fructifier cette
audace cette créativité
cet homme issu du 20e siècle a toujours
été à l'avant garde
il nous aura de façon remarquable
préparer au 21ème siècle par un
véritable nationalisme économique par la
fin de l' équilibre budgétaire par la
création de la cité du multimédia par la
signature de la paix des braves par
l'adoption de la loi sur l'union civile
bien sûr il y à aussi berlin landry le
grand patriote celui qui a consacré sa
vie ses énergies et ses talents
promouvoir le québec sur toutes les
tribunes de façon si volontaire et
convaincante
il souhaitait plus que tout faire du
québec un pays
une étape comme les autres
qu'y apporterait une importante
contribution à l'humanité en étant un
état disposant de tous ses pouvoirs mais
aussi entièrement responsable de ses
décisions
il souhaitait qu'enfin le québec juste
passer du statut de locataire à celui de
propriétaire monsieur landry aurait été
disposés pour nous ses amis jusqu'à la
fin
c'est admirable et c'est très
représentatif de l'homme généreux et
plein de considération qu'il était
monsieur landry les conseils que vous
m'avez offert lors de notre dernière
rencontre récente me guideront pour la
suite et prennent maintenant la lure de
testament politique
je continuerai à tenter de convaincre le
plus grand nombre possible de joindre
nos rangs du parti de la liberté vous
avez manier les mots et les chips si
bien avec éloquence et discernement
vous étiez un modèle 2010 début au parti
québécois
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je souhaite que nous
gardons toujours en haut cette flamme
éternelle qui brûlait en vous et que
vous avez allumé chez nombre de ceux qui
sont ici aujourd'hui
cette flamme dont le combustible infinie
et l'amour du québec
l'amour de sa patrie comme vous le
disiez il ya d'autres horizons à
découvrir d'autres bonheur à partager en
reprenant les mots de gaston miron que
vous aimiez tant vous n'avez jamais
voyagé vers aux deux pays que votre pays
le québec bouziri s'ils vont continuer
ce voyage avec vos esprits en tête
nous allons continuer et lorsqu'on verra
le grand drapeau national du québec le
seul auquel vous avez prêté allégeance
lorsqu on verra ce mouvement dans le
ciel on se retire votre souffle qui
s'ajoutent aux mouvements du québec
merci pour tout le suc patriotes de
verchères nous vous aimons
madame louise harel ancien ministre et
première femme nommée d'ailleurs par
monsieur landry à devenir présidente de
l'assemblée nationale du québec
mesdames et messieurs les dignitaires le
sud comme ministre françois madame la
première ministre
ami de bernard les mots sont impuissants
pour exprimer l'émotion qui mettrait et
qui nous aiderait elle a pensé que
bernard ne soit plus parmi nous et
puisse le déferlement d'affection et
d'amour dont nous a parlé pascal puisse
se venir vous réconforter
chantal les enfants et toute la grande
famille la famille sa grande famille
qu'il aimait tant
bernard ce patriote moderne qui a ravivé
dans nos vies le mot patrie nous laisse
un héritage est destructible la
démonstration que nous formons un peuple
libre de son destin et possédant la
pleine capacité de sa liberté il est
soucis en héritage la nécessité de
conjuguer prospérité économique et
solidarité sociale
bernard croyait fermement un québec à la
fois prospère et solidaire
la dernière fois que j'ai vu à verchères
merci chère chantal il m'a rappelée
affectueusement ce qu'il a souvent eu
plaisir à me dire dans le passé que nous
étions les deux faces d'une même pièce
lui qui s'employait à créer la richesse
et moi la distribuer
il aimait déclaré que la main invisible
d'adam smith avait besoin d aide
convenons que bernard n'a pas ménagé son
aide pour assurer un meilleur partage la
richesse et une vigoureuse création
d'emplois il fut partie prenante de la
social démocratie à la québécoise ce
modèle singulier en amérique du nord
l'époque du déficit zéro fut aussi une
époque faste d'intervention majeur pour
améliorer la vie des gens
assurance médicaments congés parentaux
accès logis centres de la petite enfance
équité salariale reconnaissance de
l'économie sociale loi anti pauvreté et
combien d'autres auxquelles bernard
comme plusieurs de nos collègues furent
associés la conscience nationale qui
animait bernard embrasé la totalité de
la nation sans rejet ni exclusion
sociale
moi aussi je termine avec l'hiver de
gaston miron qui l'aiment et à nous
déclare mais avec éloquence
n'est ce pas pascal d'ailleurs vous le
dis mais je crois utile de nous le
répéter tant il nous l'a dit plusieurs
fois je n'ai jamais voyagé vers autres
pays que toi mon pays
merci
son cher ami gilles baril
chantal pascal mme julie philippe la
famille monsieur le premier ministre les
invités dignitaires amis et citoyens
bernard compagnon ami et père de la
patrie longtemps tue à exercer auprès de
moi le rôle de guide et de père
d'inspirateur et de compagnons de
modèles et de source infinie d'affection
parce que notre étincelle de servir tu
la regardait avec affection notre is
here de notre désir de faire plus pour
le québec sur le transformait en
compagnon de la libération et de notre
condition humaine d'hommes qui nous
guide vers quelque chose de plus grand
que nous tue donnait du sens à notre vie
à notre existence avec toi il y avait un
bus une trajectoire une forme de sacré
devant l'univers
aujourd'hui tout le québec taux rend
hommage par la parole mais aussi par un
silence plein de reconnaissance mais tu
savais que la route des hommes étaient
faits aussi d'amour de la patrie
s'ils savaient que la route des papes
était fait du rêve des vallées
verdoyantes tu savais que la route
quotidienne des hommes étaient faites
également de bienveillance et de
générosité
tu savais que tous ensemble
individuellement comme collectivement on
pouvait faire mieux pour le bien commun
et comme le général de gaulle
que tu admirais il fallait de la
grandeur parce que tu savais que le
québec et les québécois sont meilleures
lorsqu'on leur propose quelque chose de
plus grand cette grande ah oui nous
l'avons tous reçu un moment où l'eau de
notre vie dans nos discussions avec toi
et puis tu nous a dit et répété que la
meilleure façon de servir sa patrie
c'était de l'est mais aujourd'hui bien
des personnes de toutes les générations
se sont reconnaissantes de cela et s'il
ya une certitude même avec le vide de
ton départ pour moi et pour les
québécois j'en suis certain c'est
l'espérance que tu as fait naître en
nous parce que nous sommes je peux te
dire bernard les fils et les filles de
cette patrie là que tu as time ne te
surprend pas par cette immense vague
d'amour dtb quoi que tu reçois il est
aussi grand que celui que tu nous as
donné partout sur la planète
comme dans toutes les régions du québec
il y à des entrepreneurs des étudiants
du travail à des artistes qui réalise
tous les jours une partie des rêves du
québec que tu as se met en eux oui
bernard tu as laissé quelque chose qui
résonne dans la marche de notre humanité
et de notre destin collectif grande l
émotion qui nous habite berne à grains
est immense le souvenir on hérite grande
l histoire et elle n'est pas terminée
grande est l'espérance à laquelle nous a
toujours habitués et il n'est pas
question comme dirait le poète gaston
miron de laisser tomber l'espérance en
sus fait et fera toujours partie des
immortels phare de notre histoire
collective
adieu compagnons et amis importe avec
toi mon amour éternel et celui de tes
millions de compatriotes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des oiseaux
[Applaudissements]
et parce haye
[Musique]
aso
oui
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
mais sans bande à temps
oui
[Musique]
n'est pas
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson en mémoire de feu lorraine
laporte
les trois personnes qui vont témoigner
maintenant représente certes l'amitié
mais aussi cette diversité inclusive du
québec de bernard landry
j'appelle à monter sur scène en même
temps monsieur maka kotto madame djemila
benhabib et monsieur daniel amar
[Applaudissements]
chatel julie philippe pascal membres de
la famille et amis
votre excellence monseigneur du pin
monsieur le gouverneur général monsieur
le premier ministre
madame et messieurs les premiers
ministres et dames et messieurs les
dignitaires concitoyennes concitoyens
bernard je me souviens macquart tué mon
frère
ce sont tes dernier mot lors de notre
toute première conversation il y a de
cela 16 ans le 2 novembre 2002 parce que
nous avons partagé le même humanisme les
mêmes aspirations les mêmes rêves aussi
parce que nous nous sommes indignés des
mêmes choses
tu m'a appelé mon frère et je t'ai
appelé mon frère
et c'est avec ton coeur ardent est grand
que tu m'a insufflé le sentiment du nom
de ton amour pour le québec
tu m'as contaminé puis tu m'as
précipiter dans l'univers impitoyable de
la politique active mais je ne t'en veux
pas pour tout cela mon frère car grâce à
toi j'ai eu l'opportunité d'y faire une
différence dans la vie d'un bon nombre
et d'y rencontrer la femme de ma vie
bernard nous ne pouvions te rendre
hommage sans d'abord je crois être à
l'écouté de tomans racines mans affectif
psychique presque charnelle au coeur du
destin de québec
des études disent avoir des engagements
ton propre aux désirs des exigences
vis-à-vis de toi même vis-à-vis des
autres sont comme des substances et
généreuse qui gonfle sans tarir ta vie
qui a épousé les plus grandes valeurs
humaines pour servir le québec et
l'humanité
rien chez toi ne dictait le repos et ce
jusqu'à ton dernier souffle de tes
succès et de tes échecs
nous avons appris tu nous a appris qu'il
fallait prendre consciemment notre place
dans l'histoire est que d'humanité ne
doit pas se faire par l'effacement des 1
au profit d'autrui
tu nous a appris que l'ambition et la
gloire personnelle ne devait jamais être
une source de motivation
tu nous as prêt à être de puissants
exemple d
sic mais oui tu nous a surtout appris à
aimer le québec et que nous devions voir
grand pour la patrie nos dernières
comptent discussions ont porté
essentiellement sur la diversité
québécoise tu étais préoccupé par deux
déficits selon lien avec les québécois
issus de la diversité
le décifit le déficit dis-je du
sentiment d'appartenance et celui
relatif aux sentiments d'acceptation des
solutions tu en avais plein la tête
au delà de la lutte contre le racisme et
la discrimination
tu voulais voir s'inscrire davantage de
modèles de référence et d'identification
issus de la diversité dans l'imaginaire
collectif à travers les arts la culture
la politique
ces véhicules disait tu aurait un impact
majeur dans la construction de notre
mémoire collectif le nous bernard tu
ignores le nombre de vies que tu as pu
toucher au cours de son existence
terrestre
tu es loin très loin d'imaginer l'impact
que tu as eue sur nous maintenant le
plus grand de tes droits et de savoir
que notamment le québec thème merci a
bientot mon frère
[Applaudissements]
sur chantal cher pascal cher philippe
chère julie jardini terre gerda me
bernard le patriote des lumières comment
évoquer la mémoire d'un géant aux
convictions fortes
féru de politique internationale pétri
de culture friands de musique et
boulimique de lecture
que retenir du legs inestimable d'un
immense patriotes droit comme un pic
tendre et blagueur à la pensée féconde à
la parole forte et mobilisatrice et à
l'action salvatrice et visionnaire
monsieur landry aimait la vie et les
êtres goulûment passionnément ardemment
d'un amour fou doux et brûlant il était
lui-même enveloppé d'amour celui des
trois femmes de sa vie sa mère thérèse
granger ses épouses lorraine laporte et
chantal renaud celui de ses enfants
pascal joly et philippe ses petits
enfants sept arrière petits enfants
l'amour du monde et infi dire une sorte
de garde-fou contre la rudesse et la
cruauté de la vie politique
préserver ses yeux de la laideur de
façon à pouvoir se perdre dans la beauté
du grand fleuve en toutes circonstances
est ainsi dire une nécessité pour
quiconque s'engage dans la vie publique
car nul ne peut prétendre au bo sans en
être profondément imprégné certes
monsieur landry aurait pu choisir de
traverser son temps avec détachement
car sa vie aurait été probablement moins
agitée plus tranquille moins tumultueuse
sauf que cette vie là plus ou moins
ranger ne l'intéressé pas pour un être
de cette sensibilité si rare de cette
intelligence
vive l'ennui prenait la forme de
l'immobilisme
pas question d'y succomber la vie n'est
pas un courant des retours même le monde
appartient ceux qui luttent disait le
grand hugo et monsieur landry était de
ceux-là un battant c'est être
profondément enracinée dans notre
histoire commune s'est lancée vers le
monde avec aisance et légèreté
c'est bien simple il planait alors que
d'autres peiné à marcher le québec des
années 50 grouillait d'une volonté
insatiable de changement en ce temps là
la vie portait en elle la promesse d'une
histoire inédite et palpitante
faut-il rappeler cette banalité nous ne
savons jamais par avance ce que la vie
sera c'est là que la touche de l'homme
devient essentiel pour toute réalisation
petites et grandes de cette possibilité
de changement l'homme est porteur par
nature c'est-à-dire par naissance bâtir
créer innover agir pour cela il fallait
d'abord changer le regard que nous
avions sur nous mêmes nous les québécois
il fallait nous redonner confiance
collectivement il fallait nous
requinquer nous bousculer nous
convaincre qu'il n'y avait rien de
suspicieux à prétendre à l'excellence et
rien de méprisant à lorgner la richesse
il fallait nous sortir des bâtons de
l'aliénation politique économique
culturelle et linguistique pour nous
placer dans les lumières dans l'agir
politique comme dirait hannah arendt
il fallait oser penser exister par
nous-mêmes bref il fallait nous faire
naître différemment autrement
monsieur landry appartient à une
génération exceptionnelle à qui nous
devons immensément changer le regard que
nous avons sur nous-mêmes saison c'est
sans aucun doute la plus grande des
révolutions que les humains
accomplissent sur eux mêmes leur révolue
son copernicienne qui d'autre mieux que
lui pour nous faire réfléchir sur notre
propre condition d'accord c'est pas
l'enfer ici loin dollars surtout après
les accomplissements des années soixante
et soixante dix notre situation s'est
améliorée grandement elle est loin
d'être misérable mais raison de plus
pourquoi se contenter du moindre
lorsqu'on peut aspirer aux meilleurs
mais imaginez gaza pourrait être si nous
cessions de tourner en rond
n'ayons pas peur des mots et si nous
devenions libre pas seulement en raison
de simples considérations économiques
quoique la prospérité ce bien ce même
très bien sauf que pour habiter le monde
il faut plus faut-il encore avoir une
spécificité un cachet une posture une
identité une âme au sens de dostoïevski
une culture au sens de braudel monsieur
landry cannes et c'est cette idée
d'indépendance
comme une exigence incessante et
pressante une obsession une obsession
presque maladive
mais peut-on reprocher un patriote de
trop aimer sa patrie sa nation son
peuple d'ailleurs at on déjà vu un jour
un patriote nourrir d'avoir trop aimé
les siens servir sa patrie et bien
entendu de loin la responsabilité
première de chaque patriote
cette assignation à résidence dans
l'étroitesse d'un statut dont nous
restons désespérément tributaire le
blesser profondément parce qu'il était
convaincu de notre formidable potentiel
à contribuer pleinement à l'essor de
l'humanité
comment dire en préservant notre culture
nous participons à la préservation du
monde en ce sens
la diversité des cultures et des
identités nationales
c'est ce qui fonde la richesse de notre
patrimoine universel
l'homogénéisation des marchés exigent la
pluralité des cultures
je me souviens de façon précise du
moment où il a évoqué ce que je viens
d'énoncer ici avec évidemment plus
d'élégance
il a aussitôt fait le parallèle avec la
biodiversité
j'étais ébloui par la puissance de cette
pensée profonde
je venais de percuter d'allumer de
comprendre s'il y aura toujours quelque
part un endroit dans le monde pour
fabriquer des engins des autos des
avions des stylos des tables des chaises
que sais-je bref des bébelles il nouera
nulle part ailleurs dans le monde un
espace pour appréhender l'humanité tel
que nous le faisons nous nous le peuple
québécois
si notre culture s'étiole ce père
disparaît s'efface c'est une partie de
l'humanité qui s'éteint autrement dit
notre propre notre rapport au monde ne
peut se résumer à un chiffre c'est une
vision de l'humanité que l'on porte en
nous c'est notre plus grande
contribution à l'épopée humaine
voilà une idée forte central de la
pensée politique de monsieur landry une
autre avenue tout aussi puissante qui a
structuré son cheminement intellectuel
ces dernières années consistait à
réfléchir sur les conditions de
préservation de notre culture et de
notre identité nationale
si particulière en amérique du nord
qu'il faille valoriser la diversité et
se réjouir de la richesse linguistique
et culturelle qui constitue le québec
d'aujourd'hui cela allait de soi pour
lui il en était immensément fier lui qui
parlait parfaitement bien l'anglais
et l'espagnol et qui avait enseigné en
chine et en egypte entre autres pour
autant il était réfractaire à l'idée de
reconnaître d'autres communautés avec
des droits spécifiques
il voyait là même un grave danger
une possibilité de fragmentation de
notre nation en une multitude de petites
communautés qui se tournent le dos les
uns aux autres
le seul espace de convergence de toutes
et de tous de chacune et de chacun qu'il
privilégiée était la nation notre seul
port d'attache politique monsieur landry
y aller encore plus loin dans son
raisonnement il était convaincu que ce
qui donne consistance à une existence ne
venait pas du seul registre de nos
inscriptions native en ce sens
monsieur landry était un homme des
lumières ce qui importe ce n'est pas
d'où nous venons mais ce que nous
tendons à être ce que nous voulons être
ce que nous aspirons à accomplir
ensemble pour le québec
je le revois encore échanger avec nous
lors d'une soirée que j'organisais au
centre humaniste de montréal le 15
décembre 2015 qui réunissait des
immigrants venus d'afghanistan d'iran
d'egypte d'israël de syrie du maroc
d'algérie de tunisie et du sénégal qui
d'autre mieux que lui pour saisir la
fragilité de la condition humaine de nos
destins fracassés et de nos vie
chamboulée pour nous le québec était une
délivrance
une renaissance la vie d'un patriote
n'est pas de tout repos car à chaque
fois que nous pensons avoir atteint le
sommet ce dernier s'éloigne de nous ou
nous de lui
allez savoir à l'image de sisyphe à
plusieurs tout devient compliqué nous ne
marchons pas tous à la même cadence
il nous arrive même de faire du surplace
de reculer de subir des défaites de
connaître des échecs
alors on frôle précipice on peut manquer
de disciples
de rigueur de hauteur le chaos nous
guette monsieur landry a traversé toutes
ces épreuves sans jamais perdre pied il
a toujours maintenu sa flamme allumée en
plus de garder celles des autres bien
vivante
c'était un mobilisateur n'est par les
convaincre transmettre le goût du pays
était chez lui un réflexe naturel une
vocation
si bien qu'à chaque fois que nous avions
besoin d'un orateur exceptionnel un
militant prononcer le nom de monsieur
landry voulez vous qu'on l'appelle c'est
ainsi que je l' ai vu débarquer un jour
avec son ange gardien et son garde du
corps la merveilleuse chantal dans une
salle bondée du 15e arrondissement de
paris pour y prononcer le mot
d'introduction d'une conférence sur le
multiculturalisme je revois chante à lui
d'y en parle dans le micro chéri
l'introduction s'est transformé en un
développement
monsieur landry tenait toujours le micro
il s'est tourné vers la l'animateur
brice couturier chroniqueur à france
culture pour lui demander s'il avait
puisé son temps ce dernier lui répondit
un peu gêné premier ministre alors je
continue poursuivi monsieur landry
mathieu bock côté le prochain orateurs
souriez monsieur landry était
immensément heureux comme à chaque fois
qu'il venait en france parce qu'il était
entouré de sa tribu car de tous les pays
qu'ils connaissaient c'est de loin la
france qu'il aimait le plus pour sa
culture et son histoire et son apport
pour le québec
nous avons fini notre soirée dans un
bistrot autour du plat national français
le couscous
il aimait répéter le fait que benhabib
il soit devenu un patronyme québécois
certes comme tant d'autres patronyme
venus d'ailleurs car le québec
magnifique terre d'accueil n'a cessé de
faire de la place aux autres
je le regardais avec émotion pour moi
qui suis né en ukraine d'un père
algérien et d'une mère chypriotes grecs
landry fait partie de mon patrimoine
symbolique
cet héritage si précieux je le garderais
jalousement je le porterai toujours avec
dignité fierté et une immense
reconnaissance
merci monsieur landry de m'avoir fait
grandir de m'avoir fait aimer le québec
d'un amour réfléchi d'un amour charnel
et sensuel
merci chantal pour ton amitié
chaleureuse et joyeuse
[Applaudissements]
monseigneur monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur bouchard ce char et sur pauline
très chère chantal julie philippe pascal
dans ce concert d'éloges si méritée
merci de m'offrir le privilège de saluer
mon premier ministre de lui rendre un
ultime hommage en rappelant une facette
peu connue de son action ses liens avec
les communautés ethnoculturelles et la
communauté juive en particulier les
communautés culturelles
bernard landry les avait toutes
apprivoiser il connaissait les
dirigeants leur président il est
empathique reconnaissant à l'endroit de
ceux qui avaient lié leur destin au
destin du québec
il comprenait leurs difficultés et la
douleur de l'exil lui qui affectionne et
en ce fameux verre de gaston miron
repris par louise harel et pascal bérubé
aucune allocution sur l'immigration ont
été prononcées sans qu'il ne manifeste
son affection pour le peuple haïtien qui
en dépit des tragédies n'avait jamais
céder sur sa dignité sa souveraineté il
admirait les kabyles si attachés à leurs
spécificités
j'avais vécu douloureusement la tuerie à
la mosquée de québec le bien-être des
communautés d'habiter son québec était
plurielle inclusif et généreux ouvert
sur la diversité un québec où les
enfants de l'immigration étaient invités
à prendre le relais des artisans de
notre modernité
durant la campagne de son protégé david
levin sur un ton taquin il m'avait dit
un jour les juifs sont des québécois
puis me fixant droit dans les yeux
les marocains sont si des québécois
sourire en coin je lui rappelais que
j'étais les deux à la fois il m'avait
alors répondu toi tu as beaucoup de
chance tu es deux fois québécois
il aimait trop son pays pour ne pas le
partager son patriotisme était celui du
coeur pour lui
l'appartenance au québec ne pouvait
découler d'un hasard biologique ou la
généalogie mais de la volonté d'y vivre
et de s'y enraciner dans sa perspective
la souveraineté était une main tendue à
l'ensemble des communautés culturelles
ouvrait la porte à la construction
collective d'un nouveau pays où la
notion de communauté et de minorités
s'effacerait devant l'épanouissement
d'une seule communauté de destin une
communauté nationale
homme de coeur et de culture bernhard
langer entretenu avec la communauté
juive une relation particulière ils
nourrissent envers elle une affection
profonde à la mesure de son engagement
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
il prenait d'ailleurs plaisir à rappeler
qu'en votant 1832 en faveur de
l'émancipation politique des juifs
le québec avait devancé la décision du
parlement de londres d'un quart de
siècle il avait symboliquement réservé
sa première sortie publique comme
premier ministre à cette communauté
durant son intervention chaudement
applaudie il rappela la citation du
célèbre historien arnold toynbee après
une catastrophe nucléaire
deux peuples survivront et chinois par
leur nombre
les canadiens français par leur
obstination une manière de rappeler que
les québécois partagent avec les juifs
cette farouche volonté de traverser les
siècles et le désir indescriptible
d'être acteur et non plus spectateur de
leur propre destin marqué par les
dérives et les tourments du 20e siècle
ils avaient filmé en sait à quel point
le low cost et israël représenter des
marqueurs identitaires pour cette
communauté membres de son cabinet je
l'avais informé à l'époque de la
décision arrêtée par des fonctionnaires
de décliner une demande de soutien du
musée morel et de l'holocauste en raison
de restrictions budgétaires
il avait immédiatement réagi convaincu
que par devoir de mémoire nous ne
pouvions faire l'économie d'un lieu qui
immunise contre la barbarie
le prix nobel de la paix shimon perez
entretenait avec le patriote de
verchères une belle complicité
au point de solliciter son appui pour
développer un parc industriel et
technologique rassemblant israéliens
palestiniens québécois les tensions dans
la région auront eu malheureusement
raison de cet audacieux projet j'aurais
bien des anecdotes à raconter
témoignant des relations d'amitié de
complicité qu'il entretenait avec cette
communauté et la communauté le lui
rendait bien lui réservant avec chantal
renaud si merveilleuse et dévoué une
place d'honneur à toutes les
manifestations majeures président du
festival du cinéma israélien
conférencier dans le cadre du festival
séfarad honoré par le consul général
d'israël lors de la fête nationale était
présent à tous les grands événements
certes les relations ont été parfois
animés mais bernard landry comprenait
les réticences de la communauté juive
face au projet souverainiste pour
reprendre ses mots il souhaitait que
cette communauté soit plus québécoise
que les québécois parce que les juifs
avaient toujours contribué aux victoires
de l'esprit et à l'avancement de leur
pays
une plaisanterie qui me rappelait tout
dernièrement circulaient d'ailleurs à ce
sujet le grand rabbin du québec en
discussion avec le bon dieu se plaignait
d'avoir obtenu au paradis un simple
quatre et demi alors qu'un immense
palais était réservée à bernard landry
et le bon dieu de répondre rabhi à la
synagogue quand tu parlais de tora tout
le monde dormait mais quand bernard
landry parler de souveraineté
tout le monde criait
la communauté juive reconnaissant
bernard landry un profond d'humanisme et
un sens aigu de la démocratie voyant en
lui le porteur d'une conscience des
droits des minorités
chères familles difficile en quelques
mots de résumer une existence dans
capitulé une essence de rendre hommage à
cette figure si emblématique du projet
souverainiste mais je voudrais dire à
monsieur landry que jolie conservant
l'admiration mon respect et ma gratitude
pour avoir permis de participer à cette
magnifique aventure collective de servir
le québec ait d'abord été le témoin
privilégié d'un chapitre lumineux de
notre histoire et comme je suis deux
fois québécois alors je lui dis shalom
salam chers amis
pour terminer les témoignages mesdames
et messieurs
monsieur landry voulait que le
sociologue mathieu pour coter vous
adresser la parole
[Applaudissements]
chère chantal membres de la famille
messieurs et dames les dignitaires sur
le premier ministre laissez moi d'abord
vous confier un souvenir personnel à
propos de monsieur landry alors que
j'avais 18 ans et que j'étais un tout
jeune homme très pressé de participer à
la vie de la cité
on m'avait demandé dans le cadre de
l'émission de télévision d'interviewer
mon idole mon idole c'était bernard
landry il était vice premier ministre du
québec
et pourtant il a trouvé le temps de
mourir une heure ce bel exercice
je n'en revenais pas et je crois que je
n'en reviens toujours pas
monsieur landry était un grand pédagogue
et aimer la jeunesse même lorsqu'elle se
prenait pour bernard pivot
au fil du temps nous nous sommes souvent
croisés et j'ai même eu le bonheur de
travailler à son cabinet au fil du temps
nous sommes devenus amis et de cette
amitié je tire une grande fierté
nous sommes des milliers à pouvoir et
puis un souvenir du même genre pour cet
homme qui aimait son pays qui émet son
peuple qui aimer sa patrie
on le sait la grande cause qui a
traversé l'existence bernard landry
c'est l'indépendance du québec
dès ses premières années dans l'âge
adulte et jusqu'à ces dernières secondes
il n'a cessé d'y louer ses pensées ses
espérances ses efforts cette construit
verse notre histoire
s'il a trouvé son plein élan avec la
révolution tranquille son histoire ne
commence pas avec elle et cela bernard
landry le c est lui qui aimait rappeler
la mémoire des pionniers du grand-père
nationale et c'est parce qu'il avait une
mémoire l'ombre du combat national que
bernard landry savez traverser les
périodes difficiles sans désespérer
depuis plus de deux siècles d'une
manière ou d'une autre
l'idée d'indépendance habite notre
conscience collective elle interpelle
les coeurs les plus nobles certaine
génération et la responsabilité de
garder la flamme vivante d'autres de la
ranimer quand elle risque est s'éteindre
mais toujours il y eut un noyau
d'irréductibles de patriotes fidèles
auxquels ils appartenaient pour rappeler
que nous ne sommes pas sur cette terre
simplement pour survivre mais pour vivre
pleinement comme un peuple libre nous
deux on ne doute en plus de son droit
d'être maître chez lui bernard landry a
fait partie de la génération qui a plus
possible de relancer la charge pour
l'indépendance et elle est passée à deux
doigts
de l'emporter l'indépendance n'est ni à
gauche ni à droite mais en avance
bernard landry c'est une question
d'honneur et de liberté nous aurions
intérêt à méditer cette phrase dans
l'otan de division en ré âprement à
mettre la patrie au dessus des partis
une dernière chose bernard landry était
un homme de l'enracinement et
d'universel tout à la fois sans élan
vers l'universel l'enracinement peut
devenir rabougrissement mais sans
enracinement l'élan vers l'universel
mutile l'homme et le condamne à une
existence décharné sang demeurent sans
chez soi
bernard landry et mais charnellement ce
au québec quelques semaines avant sa
mort trois semaines en fèves dans ce qui
était manifestement tournée des adieux
j'ai eu le bonheur de partager le
dernier repas avec lui à sa maison de
berchères il était physiquement affaibli
évidemment et il savait bien que les
temps sont durs pour les militants de
l'indépendance mais il était
fondamentalement optimiste quant à la
pire au fond de lui mais il ne doutait
pas de notre victoire
comme l'écrivait gaston miron miron ça
ne pourra pas toujours ne pas arriver
aujourd'hui nous sommes des centaines de
milliers en deuil d'un homme qui fut à
la fois notre chef et notre compagnon
nous pleurons sa mémoire et pourtant
demain c'est avec le sourire aux lèvres
et son souvenir à l'esprit que nous
reprendrons le combat pour le pays dont
bernard landry [ __ ] des plus beaux
soldats au moment de nous quitter il ya
trois semaines je me suis permis de
citer à monsieur landry cette phrase
essentielle de clemenceau dans la guerre
comme dans l'ain bête comme dans la
guerre comme dans la tête le dernier mot
revient à ce qu'ils n'abandonnent jamais
monsieur landry nous n'abandonnerons pas
monsieur landry nous n'abandonnerons
jamais merci
quand padres il disait dans cette langue
espagnole qui était devenu aussi la
sienne alors son message c'est beau ce
meurtre aux havraises offre aux los rios
j'ai deux missives courte on aimerait
vous lire une qui lui est elle arrivée
le 22 octobre donc bien avant sa mort
cher monsieur landry j'appris vos soucis
de santé tenet vous faire part de tout
mon soutien le temps et la distance
n'ont pas éteint le souvenir vif et
positive nos échanges qui ont mené à
l'implantation d'ubisoft au québec il ya
21 ans
que de chemin parcouru sous la grande
impulsion de 1997 où il s'offre dès à
présent profondément enracinée au québec
nos studios de montréal qui est le plus
grand studio de jeux vidéo monde de
québec piémont et saguenay continue
d'innover de rayonner sur les cinq
continents grâce au talent des jeunes
créateurs québécois un écosystème
complet a émergé compte à ce jour
à ce jour plus de 200 entreprises et
10000 emplois
vos qualités de visionnaire ont permis
cette grande réalisation
je tiens personnellement à vous
remercier à nouveau de la confiance que
vous avez personnes aujourd'hui le
québec est plus que jamais partie
intégrante du coeur d'ubisoft yves
guillemot président d'ubisoft
ea 2d j'ai appris avec tristesse décès
de mon ami bernard dans le film qui est
consacré à sa campagne électorale de
2003 à hauteur d'homme on le voyait tel
qu'il est et patriote déterminé
vigoureux il fut une figure
incontournable et respecté de la vie
politique québécoise
il avait des valeurs chevillée aux
cordes il a défendu tout au long de sa
vie de sa longue carrière politique
qu'il a menée au plus haut poste au
québec celui de premier ministre
d'ailleurs cette phase a publi
ce cash est aussi un homme d'une grande
culture notamment classique manie avec
aisance le latin nous avions partage
l'amour de la langue française
aujourd'hui je me souviens avec émotion
de nos rencontres de nos échanges de son
amitié s'adresse au peuple québécois et
aux proches de bernard landry
mes sincères condoléances à l'egypte au
alain juppé maire de bordeaux et ancien
premier ministre de la république
française et je vais terminer mon
intervention par les mots mêmes de berne
à l'envi il y a très peu de temps
12h16
l'amour de la patrie est un noble
sentiment qui doit animer chaque
citoyenne et chaque citoyen peut importe
les croyances ou les origines et quant à
moi je vous le laisse en héritage
merci mon affection
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chen
je
[Musique]
vous
et
sochaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah
jours
[Musique]
chen
lecture du livre du prophète jérémie tu
enlèves la paix à mon âme
j'ai oublié le bonheur j'ai dit mon
assurance a disparu et l'espoir qui me
venaient du seigneur rappelle toi ma
misère et mon errance l'absence et le
poison
elle se rappelle mon âme elle se
rappelle à moi elle des failles
voici ce que je redis en mon coeur et
c'est pourquoi j'espère grâce à l'amour
du seigneur nous ne sommes pas anéanti
ce sont des ses tendresses ne s'épuise
pas elle se renouvelle chaque matin oui
t'as fit état fidélité sur la bande
je me dit le seigneur est mon partage
c'est pourquoi j'espère en lui le
seigneur est bon pour qu'ils se tournent
vers lui pour celui qui le cherche
il est bon d'espérer en silence
le salut du seigneur parole du seigneur
[Musique]
oui
le mans
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
aubin
oh oui
[Musique]
oh
il est saint paul apôtre au corps et ses
frères et soeurs nous le savons celui
qui a résisté
le seigneur jésus nous ressuscitera nous
aussi avec jésus il nous placera près de
lui avec vous et tout cela est pour vous
afin que la grâce plus largement répandu
dans un plus grand nombre grâce à bond
et l'action de grâce pour la gloire de
dieu
c'est pourquoi nous ne nous ne perdons
pas courage et même si en nous l'homme
extérieur va vers sa ruine le matériel
se renouvelle de jour en jour car de
détresse du moment présent et légère par
rapport aux bois vraiment incomparable
de gloire éternelle
quels produits pour nous et notre regard
ne cesse ne s'attache pas à ce que six
appartements et notre regard ne
s'attache pas à ce qui se voit mais 6 ne
se voit pas ce qui se voit et
provisoires mais ce qui ne se voit pas
et éternelle nous le savons en effet
même si notre corps sept ans qui est
notre demeure sur l'artère est détruit
nous avons un édifice construit perdu
une demeure éternelle dans les cieux qui
n'est pas l'oeuvre des hommes parole du
seigneur
et
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
et
oh
avec vous et venger les de jésus christ
lance un jeu un certain jésus disait à
saint dit c'est que votre cas ne soit
pas bouleversée
vous croyez en dieu croyez aussi en moi
dans la maison de mon père il y à de
nombreuses demeures sinon vous aurez
jeudi je pas vous préparer une place
quand je serais parti vous préparez une
place
je reviendrai et je vous emmènerai
auprès de moi afin que là où je suis
vous soyez vous aussi pour aller où je
vais vous savez le chemin
thomas lui dit seigneur nous ne savons
pas où tu vois comment pourrions-nous
savoir le chemin
jésus lui réponds moi je suis le chemin
la vérité et la vie personne ne va vers
le père sans passer par mois à cramant
la parole de dieu
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous asseoir
en l'absence de renault chères familles
julie philippe pascal monsieur le
premier ministre
excellence et unitaire vous tous ici
présents
ensuite cette basilique où par les
médias nous venons d'entendre de
nombreux témoignages déjà véhiculés
depuis quelques jours et qui sont
rassemblées aujourd'hui dans les
messages que nous avons reçues entendu
partager il nous met devant plusieurs
valeurs qui ont été exprimées il nous
met devant une destinée aux destinées
d'un homme quelque part ce que l'on fait
dans la vie est certes très important
mam et ans que l'on devient ce qu'à
travers ce que l'on fait est aussi
important qu'elle sorte d'homme est ce
que je suis enfin de devenir à travers
des engagements travers mes actions à
travers mes paroles et je retiens
quelques-unes des valeurs qui ont été
exprimées il ya celle de patrie qui
évoque les racines ne pas oublier d'où
je viens d'où on vient
des relations humaines des racines
spirituelles des racines familiales des
la sienne qui ont aussi une histoire et
que nous accueillons dans notre coeur
pour pouvoir aller de l'avant dans la
liberté aussi dans la dignité
des mots qui est revenu souvent c'est le
mot dignité la dignité comme respect de
de l'autre comme un respect de la
personne on a évoqué de bernard landry
qui qu'il avait des adversaires qu'il
n'avait pas d'ennemis je pense i2c
résume très bien une valeur essentielle
dans une société où il ya toujours des
débats il ya toujours des différences de
croyance même des différences de
conviction des différences de
perspectives
mais comment faire valoir ses
convictions ses perspectives
ces croyances tout en respectant l'autre
qui ne les partage pas et quand
partagent d'autres
et quelque part je me permet d'aller un
peu plus loin un élément qui nous permet
de de d'exprimer qui l'on est
d'expliquer ce que l'on pense d'exprimer
ce que l'umq loi tout en respectant
l'autre dans sa valeur de personnes
c'est de ne pas oublier que nous sommes
tous des êtres humains la bible va très
loin non seulement nous sommes des êtres
humains nous avons tous la même humanité
mais nous sommes tous créés à l'image de
dieu et quelque part c'est comme notre
dignité fondamentale s'est décrit à
l'image de dieu de dieu qui est éternel
de dieu qui est amour de dieu qui était
fini de dieu qui se révèle à nous de
dieu qui a le pouvoir d' d'habiter notre
coeur et de new look ont réconforté
lorsque nous sommes dans la peine
le moment de la perte d'un être cher est
un moment
douloureux c'est un moment où tout aux
familles sont confrontées et j'exprime
toute mon affection mes condoléances
pour la famille de bernard landry dans
le temps des beaucoup de témoignages
sont donnés il ya aussi la peine qui est
dans l'âme et quelque part lorsqu'on
veut lés conforter quelqu'un qui est
dans la peine on se sent toujours un peu
démunis comment allait conforter
quelqu'un qui est dans la peine 1 des
façons c'est d'être présent et vous êtes
venus nombreux et donc le suivre par les
médias aux participants par les médias
c'est une façon d'apporter du réconfort
dans la peine de savoir qu'on est pas
seul
lorsqu'on a eu comme comme époux quimper
un premier ministe salon beaucoup de
générosité à l'homme à l'homme qui a
servi la société il ya servi la
démocratie et ça prend beaucoup de
générosité aussi à la famille parce que
avoir un père qui est un homme d'état
c'est aussi partager son père avec la
société s'est partagé son père avec la
vie politique avec l'api public et dans
ce sens ça je me permets de remercier la
la famille les enfants l'épousé d'avoir
partagé leur perle à l'époux avec avec
la société avec la vie politique ça
demande beaucoup de générosité
une générosité partager une générosité
dont nous avons besoin parce que ça
prend des hommes et des femmes qui
s'engagent pour le bien public qui
s'engage pour le bien commun qui
s'engage pour la croissance de la
justice la croissance de la liberté la
croissance de la responsabilité la
croissance de la solidarité
l'olympique
de façon humble et simple à prendre
quelques instants de silence
[Musique]
après avoir accueilli tous les
témoignages dans un contexte de prière a
présenté au seigneur bain avant de lire
le présenter ce qu'il est pour vous ce
qui l'est pour nous elle lui présente en
toute confiance et en priant le seigneur
de l'accueillir dans son royaume qui
comme la pâte vie éternelle que dieu
construit pour nous en passant par la
construction de nos patries sur terre il
nous prépare une patrie éternelle alors
que ce sens de silence sous un train de
mesures touchent au coeur de la peine
aux yeux nous rapprocher les uns des
autres
unger à l'espérance
frères et soeurs que notre prière monde
maintenant à vanter unanime vers du
notre père qui veut sauver tous les
hommes et qui atteint notre prière pour
nous accorder le don le sa glace
seigneur écoute nous seigneur exauce
nous seigneur écoute et nous c est aussi
le gouverneur qui je suis kircher
bataille mais le germe de la vie
éternelle alimentant sa profonde
espérance afin qu'ils trouvent place
dans la maison qui perd pour la vie
éternelle
prions le seigneur écoute nous seigneur
et les os nous poursuit celle qui
s'offre dans la rame ou dans leur corps
qui sont découragés ou qui n'ont
personne auprès d'eux pour qu'ils les
aident les aides afin qu'ils ne se
croisent jamais abandonnés de dieu
prions le seigneur écoute
ce lien
les autres se noue pour toutes les
personnes engagées dans la vie politique
afin que tu les guides et les protège
dans leur noble tâche de servir au bien
commun la justice et la paix sociale
prions le seigneur celle là
ce nous pour nous tous ici rassemblés
pour ceux et celles qui n'ont pas pu
venir qui nous ont demandé de prier pour
eux prions le seigneur pour l'église
afin qu'elle révèle au monde que le
christ seigneur des vivants et des morts
prions le seigneur les hausses loup
accueille nos prières seigneur notre
dieu tué son père et tu as vu ton fils
mourir sur une croix fortifie notre foi
en sa résurrection anime notre espérance
dans la vie que toulouse a promises par
jésus le christ notre seigneur unis dans
le même esprit nous pouvons dire avec
confiance la prière que nous avons reçu
du sauveur
notre père qui êtes aux cieux que ton
nom soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne
que ta volonté sera fait sur la terre
comme au ciel de nous aujourd'hui notre
pain de ce jour par de nunoa france
quand nous pardonnons aussi à ce que
tous
entrant et et ne nous met pas à la
tentation mais délivre nous du mal car
cet emploi qui appartiennent au règne la
puissance et la doua pour les siècles
des siècles
s'est endormi dans la paix du christ
confions de à l'amour est une autre
paire dans la foi en la vie éternelle
avec respect et affection accompagnons
le de notre prière dans l'espérance de
nous retrouver un jour quand dieu nous
réunira dans la joie de son royaume
recueillons nous en pensant tout ce que
nous avons vécu avec berne a1 ce qu'il
est pour nous à ce qu'il est pour dieu
en signe de respect pour vous bernard
voici sept ans ans il monte de vendu
avec notre prière
nous espérons nous croyons plutôt soul
et susciteront en signe de cette fois je
bénis score au nom du père et du fils et
du saint-esprit payez vous asseoir
[Musique]
oh
aum
[Musique]
oh
je
[Musique]
oh
où
je
[Musique]
on
oui
[Musique]
oh
et le des profonds 10 c'est la signature
du registre des funérailles madame
morano accompagnée de la fille de
monsieur landry pascal signe ce registre
est tout à l'heure dans un instant le
drapeau sur un remis à la famille
[Musique]
l'émission une cérémonie à l'image du
patriote
c'est ainsi que monsieur landré se
définissaient comme patriotes et
aujourd'hui c'est comme si tout le monde
avait pris le relais et même chez la vie
de monsieur legault qui a dit les côtés
des quelque chose comme un grand peuple
est tout à fait monsieur legault avait
déjà utilisé cette citation dam de ceux
l'évêque souvenez-vous dans la
présentation de son cabinet il avait
prise aujourd'hui il monsieur vous dit
comment dire qui s'efforcera de mettre
en application la la maxime que monsieur
landré m étonnement cité c'est à dire de
m le la patrie au dessus du parti alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
pour monsieur moore on ne verra usage
mais il ya toutes sortes de gens qui
sont intervenus et y est j'ai trouvé
intéressant quand même de celui de
lucien bouchard qui a dit oui monsieur
landry et un grand patriote un camp
souverainiste mais c'était avant tout un
démocrate et là monsieur bouchard le
dire il avait su respecter la volonté de
la population et précédemment
aujourd'hui en plein monsieur landry et
je comprends avec raison mais
souvenez-vous à l'époque où il est parti
il n'y a pas eu son vote de confiance et
beaucoup de gens qui étaient gérés pas
soulagé mais qui ont fait en sorte de
l'aider à sortir parce qu'il ne trouvait
pas assez pressé alors que les propos de
monsieur bush à ses désirs écouter comme
disait qu'ils ont marre et on sait la
souveraineté viendra pas plusieurs c'est
comme une flamme si on tire dessus à
poussera pas alors seul monsieur landry
était indéniablement un soir en est
convaincu il l'a toujours été mais il
avait conscience de du rythme auquel la
population est apprêté
d'où la fameuse saison des idées saison
des idées mais aussi
souvenez-vous le refus de s'engager
formellement à tenir un référendum même
si on poussait dessus pilat et a dit
dans les délais possibles puis possible
ça veut tout dire que c'est pour passer
bon on le fera pas ils voulaient pas se
faire pousser
il résilie au pied du mur il disait
qu'il fallait avoir l'assurance moral de
réussir deux nouvelles versions des
conditions guère alors on voit qu'on va
aller bientôt le cercueil on s'engage
vers la dernière partie de ces
de cette célébration de la parole le
raison du dernier adieu est empli le
drapeau on va leur mettre le drapeau qui
a été mis en berne sur l'hôtel du
parlement à québec un précieux souvenir
pour la famine est il supérieur à dabou
sera remise d'abord à monsieur legault
puis ensuite à la famille donc il ya
comme le rite de passage par le premier
ministre
[Musique]
et
m
il
[Applaudissements]
et
prions le seigneur
seigneur notre dieu nous te demandons
notre frère damart ton amour la
compagnie tout au long de sa vie il
livre le maintenant de tout mal il a
quitté ce monde qui passe conduit le
auprès de toi ou n'y a plus ni deuil ni
la rue ni douleur mais la joie et la
paix avec ton fils et l'esprit saint
pour les siècles des siècles le seigneur
soit avec vous que dieu tout puissant le
bénisse le père le fils et le
saint-esprit que toutes marques
d'affection tout geste d'amitié que vous
donnerez soit aux routines de cette paix
qu ensemble nous avons cherché à l'est
dans la paix du christ
[Musique]
oh
c'est
[Musique]
je
michaud
[Musique]
et
chine
c'est fait
shi
c 'est
c
[Musique]
je t'aime
chaud
[Musique]
tu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
i
je t'aime
chaud
[Musique]
je le
où
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais qu'at-on
dernier hommage au premier ministre
bernard landry à l'issue de cette
cérémonie de la parole
hommage au premier ministre aux
patriotes à l'ennemi à la famille
politique aussi bien qu'à la famille
proche
quel moment d'émotion à la fin c'est un
des moments forts de cette cérémonie
d'avoir choisi relatent leurs fontaines
je ne t'oublierai jamais je rappeler en
début d'émission que c'est un chant du
15e siècle qu'on en france mais que les
coureurs de bois dit si on chantait que
c'est devenu l'hymne de papel nationale
des patriotes donc jusqu'à jusqu'à la
dernière seconde
michel et sébastien on peut parler de
bernard landry
le patriote et le choix de chantal leur
nom aussi semble-t-il tout tout est
mélangé dans cet arrêt dans ce dernier
chante l'amour de chantal renaud il ya
longtemps que je t'aime jamais je ne
t'oublierai l'hymne et des patriotes
aussi ce qui représentait donc monsieur
monsieur landry bref ça résume en une
chanson ce qui était monsieur là pour
vous messieurs
oui tout à fait c'est tout c'est une
berceuse que bercé notre enfance tous
mais c'est toujours un moment d'émotion
quand on voit un acteur de premier plan
de l'histoire récente quitté la scène
alors tout le monde le dit les
adversaires comme les amis de monsieur
landry c'était un homme qui aimait
profondément ce qu'il veut mais pour les
souverainistes ça se double d'un moment
de nostalgie parce que avec monsieur
avec monsieur landry c'est un des
derniers grands témoins d'une époque où
le rêve semble est encore à portée de
main je vous rappelle que quand il est
parti la souveraineté et à 55 % dans les
sondages ça va l'air d'être simplement
une question de temps bon maintenant on
voit que le passage du temps pas parfait
l'oeuvre que les souverainistes aurait
souhaité et dans le match qu'il a rendus
à monsieur landry
durant la cérémonie la chef intérimaire
du pq pascal bérubé commencent à dire
que là il faut reprendre le flambeau
mais comment on reprend seul honnêtement
c'est pas évident pour les
souverainistes le ils se réunissent en
fait une semaine pour vaincre une
première analyse de l'élection la
confiance qu'on appelle la conférence
des présidents président du parti
québécois qui vont commencer à réfléchir
à tout ça mais c'est ma sais comment
c'est là que ça fait 20 ans qu'ils y
pensent au commun avait lancé la saison
des idées après la défaite et l'école de
2003 pour essayer de renouveler l'offre
politique du parti québécois on revient
un peu à la case départ d'une certaine
façon avec la redéfinition de l'adn du
pq et cette remise en question du
particulier et dans les moments forts de
cette série de témoignages forts et
michel lucien bouchard qui a inscrit
l'engagement de dents landru dans
l'histoire est remonté jusqu'à henri
bourassa oui tout à fait je pense aussi
serait capable de citer presque de
mémoire le fameux discours de l'église
notre dame ouest un moment fort mais ce
mouchard mais monsieur legault aussi qui
est le premier ministre des tno hf2
de la nation crie bon malheureusement il
s'est adressé ce 1 seulement en anglais
on n'a pas pu comprendre enfin que tout
le monde n'y a pas de traduction mais
siddiqui a déjà compris ça avait été un
moment important non seulement pour les
québécois mais pour l'écrit aussi ça te
fait des braves là et les sautes de ça
je pense qu'on sera toujours au dover de
monsieur tête leur appui quand il dit la
première rencontre
vous vous il avait posé une question
vous venue des wc communs canadiens
québécois
il lui a répondu un mot en crimes qu'ils
entendaient di pippo le pis pour les
temps pour qui qui vu le taux
détermination requise et est beaucoup en
commun
on va se revoir exactement faire son
analyse sattler mutuellement mon frère
alors il y avait un lien je pense très
fort qui s'étaient créés entre être
monsieur landry et monsieur moussa ce
moment et cette paix des braves fait
école dans la mesure où dans la campagne
entre à 2018 monsieur legault a ramené
ce thème là que il voulait proposer la
paix des braves 2.0 donc je tenais bonne
c'est un événement charnière dans la
relation entre les peuples autochtones
et le gouvernement du québec
à ce moment là mais qui n'a pas encore
fait de petits y ait pas eu de renvoi la
cité du sud on le voit avec le projet
puis nous lasser l'occasion des 10 ans
d'un nouveau point arias et ce n'est pas
évident on va voir en valais
un druide belval sur le parvis puisque
les gens sortent tranquillement avec
sans doute dans leur coeur ces
témoignages alors louis
oui vous avez mari il ya un tout petit
instant j'ai été en compagnie de jean
claude labrecque celui qui a réalisé le
documentaire à hauteur d'homme vous vous
souviendrez ou vraiment jean claude
labrecque avait eu un accès absolument
illimité ou presque à bernard landry à
son entourage y avait à ses côtés mme
monique simard qui faisait partie de
l'équipe de production et à titre je
crois bien de deux productrices
exécutives sur ce tournage là il me
mentionnait tous les deux jusqu'à quel
point bernard landry avait fait preuve
d'une grande générosité et une très
grande ouverture à cette époque et parce
qu'ils nous ont mentionné tout
simplement c'est que véritablement
encore une fois avec cette cérémonie que
bernard landry avait planifié dans ses
grandes lignes mais encore une fois
c'était vraiment un geste d'ouverture et
de très grande générosité
il y avait là un aéropage vraiment de
personnalités de tous les milieux
on a vu lucien bouchard bien sûr mais
également jean charest qui a été
extrêmement touché de cette attention de
la part de berne entre alors vraiment
une cérémonie qui était selon les
personnes à qui j'ai eu l'occasion de
parler tout alla vraiment l'image de
perdant là michel qu'est ce qu'on va
finalement retenir de bernard landry est
ce que ça va redonner est-ce qu'on va
prendre son héritage économique
politique sociale aussi et c'est que
certains vont prendre le relais
il ya des choses qui sont des jeux des
acquis concrets dont on lui sera
redevable le calcul québec soit devenue
une capitale du numérique jeu
donnez qu'ubisoft ça c'est un acquis
indiscutable toute la commande
l'assurance que les que les québécois
ont pris dans leur capacité de gérer de
l'économie de mener des projets je pense
que monsieur landry a beaucoup contribué
à ça comme monsieur parizeau avant lui
évidemment la grande question c'est
est-ce que les souverainistes vont être
capables de reprendre à leur compte la
commande la force de conviction de
monsieur landry et reprendre la
pédagogie de la souveraineté associée
landry faut lui reconnaître qu' il était
un formidable pédagogue de la
souveraineté surtout delà de la
dimension économique de la souveraineté
quand ils nous racontaient comment le
fédéralisme avait joué contre les
québécois la ligne bord d'un pilote
n'est plus mais ça actuellement je pense
qu' il n'y a pas de grands tribuns
actuellement
au sein du duo jean martin aussant qui
devront aller dans cette direction du
oui mais il ya toute une pédagogie qu'il
faut reprendre et sébastien vous le
message qui est passé je pense que sur
les hommes politiques ou les femmes
politiques l'authenticité la conviction
on a beau ne pas être pour ses
adversaires politiques par exemple la
même allégeance politique mais il ya un
respect qui était transmis à monsieur
landry qui a eu un passage difficile
comme premier ministre de 2001 à 2003 ça
a été un des pétales de rose à qui
marchait c'était c'était difficile pays
mais on apprend à connaître l'homme au
delà de ces deux années comme premier
ministre
oui hélas au près elle a laissé sur le
québec est dans l'esprit de la classe
politique une biographie qui s'en vient
d'ailleurs écrite par monsieur justin il
aurait pas assez près de 300 heures avec
monsieur landry aux publications patent
j'aimerais aussi dire aux gens que y
aura une messe commémorative à saint
françois xavier de verchères samedi
matin à 9h30 aucune messe à la traduire
dans son paquet pour retourner près de 5
de sa population
alors on va retenir tous à sébastien et
voir quand elle servait louvre en fait
je l'appelle au pays et dans les
discours aujourd'hui joie d'eau michel
toute sa sagesse faisait remarquer que
quand monsieur parizeau est mort il y
avait aussi ces élans l'aber la
souveraineté ça peut changer grand chose
dans l'appui au parti québécois et sur
la politique de côté rendu hommage à
monsieur le trentenaire est quand même
des discours très personnel très souvent
celle d'avant sébastien merci beaucoup
d'avoir accompagné lors de ses
funérailles d'état mesdames messieurs à
la maison merci d'avoir suivi cette
cérémonie très solennelle et innovante
restez à l'écouté merci beaucoup
[Musique]
les gens de mon pays
ce sens gens de parole et jean de
causerie qui parle pour s'entendre et
parle pour parler il faut les écouter
c'est plus que tous les hommages ce qui
le rendrait ressemble c'est que vous
tous à votre manière de continuer son
combat coin qui est des plus justes plus
fort et libre à travers l'univers mais
oui les québécois font quelque chose
comme un grand peuple et perna lundi
aura été à la hauteur
je souffre peut être qu'il a émis six
national loin en loin de celui jeu
d'isère où vous vous entêtez devant le
dessin qui vient de s'achever les congés
de s'incliner avec le respect dû à un
homme d'honneur et les convictions
infidèle et valeureux combattants
[Musique]
josé sur les perrons des portes et de
chaque côté des crayons des clôtures je
vous le match 3e rue jogues c'est mieux
vaut chemin
adieu aussi lent mais quand tu rêvais
d'une escale du temps il est question
nous vend du vent de reposer en b mon
rêve
atrium hier à notre cours de gestion
internationale vous nous avez manqué
monsieur le professeur bois dur si et
quand c'est le corner
tout ce bois attendri oui berlin je suis
allé c'est quelque chose qui résonne
dans la marche de notre humanité et de
notre destin avec qui ce week-end
maintenant le plus grand de ces droits
est de savoir que nous t'aimons le
québec thème merci a bientot mon frère
je vous entends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous en voulez
j'entends
cogner dans ma mère
[Musique]
j'entends passé
quand me classant des banques je vous
entends de ma
parler de lui
[Musique]
on